Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 145. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße wieder alle, die sich getraut haben, hier runterzuladen und zuzuschalten und einzuschalten und zuzuhören und die Augen zuzumachen und sich den ganzen Themen zu widmen, die ich mir immer wieder aus der Nase ziehe. Und heute ist mal wieder so ein Thema dran, wo vielleicht jetzt so am Anfang der Sendung mir selbst auch noch nicht so ganz klar ist, wohin eigentlich die Reise geht. Das sind ja manchmal auch die besten Sendungen. Kurz gesagt soll es gehen irgendwie um Musik, aber eigentlich auch um Programmierung und sehr viel mehr noch um die Verbindung dieser beiden Disziplinen. Wobei es mir weniger um Musik als solche geht, sondern vielleicht eher generell die Auseinandersetzung, die künstlerische Auseinandersetzung mit schönen Sachen. Das kann Musik sein, das kann aber auch genauso gut grafisches Zeug sein. Musik hier ist so ein bisschen der Aufhänger, weil das steht auch im Mittelpunkt und im Zentrum von meinem Gast und das ist Manuel Odendahl, auch bekannt als Wesen. Du machst Musik unter anderem, du baust Hardware unter anderem, du programmierst auch, du machst so allerlei Dinge und bist ja auch irgendwie Nerd, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. So fing das auch eh an, mit zwölf angefangen zu programmieren. Und dann erst mal...
In welchem Topf bist du da gefallen?
Na, mit Basic angefangen, auf dem DOS-PC. Also die erste Entwicklung, dann kam gleich auch ziemlich schnell Linux. Und danach hab ich angefangen, Informatik zu studieren, dann kam irgendwie alles auf einmal. So grad die theoretische Informatik, 1000 Programmiersprachen, grad bisschen obskurere Programmiersprachen. Lisp ist irgendwie so mein Hauptteil und dann Assembler und C++ und eigentlich so.
Hast du dieses Studium auch abgeschlossen?
Ja, das ist noch so ein bisschen in der... Also ich hab sehr, sehr, sehr tiefgehend studiert, aber zum Abschluss...
Eigentlich durch näher hier nur Leute reihen, die irgendwie auch ein abgebrochenes Informatikstudium machen.
Ja, das ist noch in der Schwebe so.
Ja, das ist ja auch schon mal eine ganze Menge. Also du bist, sag mal mal, unterstelle ich dir jetzt mal, du bist eigentlich auf einem relativ tiefen Level so mit den Dingen vertraut.
Ja, der Anfang war dann, ich hab dann auch Ewigkeiten, Unix und Wechskisten gesammelt, bin dann darüber auch auf den CCC gestoßen und hab das alles ziemlich intensiv betrieben, bis ich dann irgendwann mal so einen ziemlich starken Lebenswechsel hatte und dann angefangen habe, Musik zu machen erst mal. Und eher so, ja, das war irgendwie ein schwerer Moment so im Leben.
Das gibt es manchmal so.
Ja, das gibt es manchmal. Dann war erstmal Hacken nicht so wirklich drin und dann habe ich mich erst mal auf Musik konzentriert und da auch elektronische Musik natürlich auch ziemlich lange Zeit, Jazz-Bass gespielt, auch ziemlich intensiv und erst dann langsam wieder so zur technischen Bastel.
Was ist denn ein Jazz-Bass?
Na Bass spielen, das ist elektrischen Bass, aber in der Jazz-Band. Das sind so ein bisschen die Ninja-Kungfu-Skills, die so beim Hacken da sind, das ist so das Musik-Pendant dazu, dass er halt enorm viel Theorie haben muss, das gleichzeitig auch alles irgendwie live sofort irgendwie anzuwenden ist, weißt du so.
Enorm viel Theorie haben muss, um diesen Bass zu spielen?
Um Jazz zu spielen allgemein.
Auf dem Bass oder generell?
Auf dem Bass oder generell, um Jazz zu spielen. Und da hat der Bass dann wieder so eine besondere Rolle, weil du da eher nicht so im Vordergrund stehst, aber immer so im Hintergrund, so die Systemprogrammierung vom Jazz ist dann Bass spielen so ein bisschen. Du bist halt irgendwie...
Wirklich?
Also so sehe ich das, weil du als Bassist eigentlich immer da bist, um den Puls zu geben, den Gruf zu geben und die anderen Leute zu begleiten. Aber du bist jetzt nicht so die Vordergrund-App, du bist eher so der Colonel.
Okay, weil man so dem Gesamtklanggeschehen so was unterschiebt?
Du gibst den Rhythmus vor, weil du eigentlich immer Viertelnoten spielst, so in dem Standard-Walking-Bass und eben die ganze Harmonie vorgibst. Also mit dem Schlagzeug zusammen machst du sozusagen den Gruf und als Bass gibst du dann auch immer die Harmonie vor dem Zusammenhang mit dem Klavier dann auch. Aber du bist eigentlich immer da und spielst deine Viertelnoten so. Und das gefällt mir, glaube ich, genauso, wie ich lieber Systemprogrammierung mache als GUIs zum Bauen zum Beispiel. Es ist, glaube ich, so dasselbe Gedanke dahinter.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Das geht mir eigentlich auch so. Wobei ich selbst, also ich warte immer noch darauf, dass ich in meinem Leben noch mal einen Zugang finde zum Musikmachen. Das ist der Blitz, der mich noch nicht getroffen hat. Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich deute das jetzt einfach mal als eine entsprechende Genlücke.
Ich glaube, das sind so Sachen entweder...
Vielleicht bräuchte er noch mal einen dramatischen Lebenswechsel.
Ich meine, es sind ja eh so, bei den kreativen Bereichen hast du bestimmte, die dich einfach sofort packen und andere... Vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht schlimm, wenn du die nie machst. Ich habe jetzt auch mit dem Jazz-Spielen abgeschlossen, weil ich gemerkt habe, wenn ich es richtig machen will, so wie ich es mir vorstelle, dann ist es halt echt ein Ninja-Training, wo du halt fünf Jahre eigentlich nur das Zeugs übst.
Bis man einen schwarzen Gürtel hat und dann...
Bis man einen schwarzen Gürtel hat und dann eigentlich auch erst anfängt, sozusagen an die interessanten Sachen ranzukommen. So, dass du dann sowohl die Technik brauchst, auch diese komplette Theorie auf Abruf, dass du echt irgendwie im Tempo 300 denken musst, was ist jetzt irgendwie die Terz von... Weißt du, so musst du irgendwie drauf sein und das ist dann...
Mir war das gar nicht bewusst, dass Jazz da jetzt so eine Herausforderung darstellt.
Doch, das ist irgendwie... Es gibt natürlich viele Richtungen im Jazz, aber es ist schon so... irgendwie auch eine Poser-Musik im gewissen Sinne, das ist irgendwie... Ja, und verbindet enorm viel Theorie. Dass du eigentlich diese ganzen Regeln bzw. Nichtregeln oder Ansätze oder Konzepte erstmal verinnerlichen musst, bis du damit dann auch kreativ umgehen kannst. Und im gewissen Sinne ist es echt so wie zum Beispiel Exploitschreiben, dass du so ein enormes Detailwissen haben musst, aber wenn es dann darauf ankommt danach irgendwie einen Exploit zu schreiben, dann musst auch das alles verinnerlicht haben, um da zu wissen, wie gehe ich da jetzt so kreativ ran.
Ich dachte, man könnte da einfach sich irgendwie einen Waschbrett nehmen und dann ist man da irgendwie im Flow.
Das geht natürlich auch, das ist auch besonders schwer im gewissen Sinne. Also ich meine, auf dem Bass kannst du zwei Noten spielen und dann hörst du aber auch den deutlichen Unterschied, jemand, der das irgendwie seit 40 Jahren so geübt hat und dann immer noch zwei Noten spielt oder jemand, der die zwei Noten so spielt, wie ich dann zum Beispiel, dann merkst du, okay, das hört jeder sofort so.
Das heißt, diese Jazz-Bass-Phase als direkte Folge auf den Lebenswechsel, den du ansprachst, das ist ein bisschen mehr so deine Mönchsphase, warst du so ein bisschen das Äquivalent zum Battlemönch in Thailand, um erst mal auf die Spur zu kommen?
Na ich hatte auch gesundheitliche Probleme und das ist eben auch, also jetzt nicht vor dem Computer zu hocken, sondern wirklich irgendwie die Finger zu bewegen und so einen körperlichen Aspekt von deinem Tun zu haben, hat dann irgendwie enorm viel geholfen, deswegen habe ich es auch so intensiv betrieben. Aber dann irgendwann mal gemerkt, naja, wenn du es wirklich machen willst, so wie ich eigentlich den Anspruch immer habe, so Sachen echt auf den Grund zu gehen, dann ist es echt viel Arbeit, so wie du eigentlich zehn Jahre lang programmieren musst, bis du dann so eine gewisse Freiheit entwickelst, mit der Technik umzugehen, ist es da eigentlich genauso, nur dass dann im Endeffekt die Musik dann doch nicht unbedingt so mein Ding ist. Und ich habe dann parallel immer Techno gemacht und jetzt ist mir eigentlich deutlich lieber Techno zu machen. Und das lustigerweise auch genauso anspruchsvoll ist, wie der Jazz ist, wenn du da einfach in die Tiefe bohren kannst, bis du zu den interessanten Sachen kommst.
Jetzt bist du aber dann sozusagen auf der Techno-Spur gelandet, das ist dann doch schon eher dein Ding.
Ja, im gewissen Sinne schon. Ich finde es auch einfach, weil der Jazz vielleicht auch seine größte Entwicklungsphase hinter sich hat zum Beispiel. Dass da nicht, also zumindest nicht für mich sehe, wo die interessanten Sachen unbedingt herkommen. Die es auf jeden Fall in der elektronischen Musik, oder besonders im Techno, im Moment ziemlich gibt, wo halt jedes Jahr nicht ein Paradigmenwechsel bringt, aber wo du merkst, die Suche geht auf jeden Fall weiter und ist deutlich interessanter. Ich denke, das war beim Jazz dann in den 30ern, 40ern, 50ern, 60ern. Und danach war es dann, also für mich, dann nicht mehr unbedingt so spannend.
Das heißt, das Techno-Feld findest du auch deshalb eine Herausforderung, weil dort viel neu erfunden wird nach wie vor. Ich hatte ja hier auch mit Tarnit vor einigen Ausgaben so mal die Geschichte des Techno versucht, ein bisschen zusammenzufegen. Und ich muss sagen, den Aspekt, so wie geht es jetzt weiter, den haben wir dann gar nicht so sehr vertieft, vielleicht mal ganz interessant anzusetzen. Wo siehst du denn da so die Entwicklungen? Also was für eine Art Diversifikation und Evolution und Weiterentwicklung findet denn da statt? Also auf welcher Ebene sind das? Klänge?
Die Rhythmen sind ja nun eigentlich die gleichen. Aber da eigentlich auf ziemlich jeder Ebene. Ich denke, was mich besonders interessiert ist, dass es eben noch nicht wirklich klar ist, wie man Techno überhaupt live spielt. Es war ja lange einfach nur Platten auflegen, was ja auch ein gewisses Instrument in sich ist. Und da merkst du auch sofort, ob du einen guten DJ hast oder nicht einen guten DJ hast. Dass es aber jetzt langsam mit der ganzen technologischen Entwicklung auch möglich ist, deutlich breiter Techno live zu spielen. Das gab es von Anfang an, dass du deine 909 und deine 303 auf die Bühne geklatscht hast und damit rumgedreht hast. Was aber da auch eine gewisse Ästhetik hast und die Instrumente an sich noch ziemlich beschränkt sind. Jetzt kommt Ableton und es gibt tausend Drum-Computer und so, die ein bisschen mehr können, weil die Chips halt schneller sind. Und gerade in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren kommen plötzlich Livesets auf, die erstens richtig gut klingen, also so, als wären die von Platte gleich. Und dann trotzdem diese, wie gehe ich eigentlich überhaupt mit dem Instrument um? Also es gibt es dann auch im Jazz gerade, dass es ja eigentlich herkömmliche Instrumente sind. Und da kamen immer so bestimmte Personen, die dann von heute auf morgen das Instrument neu definiert haben, wie in den 30ern dann Charlie Parker das Saxophon erstmal irgendwie auf den Kopf gestellt hat. Und dann Miles Davis und andere Gillespie, die Trompete auf den Kopf gestellt haben. Oder so Leute wie Hendrix in den 60ern kamen und die elektrische Gitarre einfach für die nächsten, bis heutzutage einfach definiert hat. Und das gibt es, das passiert gerade im Techno oder in elektronischen Musik allgemein, das langsam sich da rauskristallisiert, wie man jetzt mit diesen Instrumenten spielt. Also du kannst einen Ableton nehmen und einfach Tracks abspielen und nichts mehr machen. Und du kannst es aber auch ganz anders gestalten. Und da ist eben das Ding, dass das Instrument an sich nicht mehr vorgegeben ist, wie bei einer Gitarre, hast du halt sechs Seiten und dann kommt es auf deutlich kleinere Details an. Sondern hast du da auch die komplette Art, was Musik eigentlich ist und was das Live-Spielen eigentlich ist, auch umdefiniert wird?
Mach das mal ein bisschen konkreter. Also was ändert sich da? Ich meine, die Wahrnehmung ist natürlich immer gut. Da hat man dann so das Programm und hat man dann diese Spuren und da plaudern dann halt irgendwie die Töne raus. Und der eine hat so die besseren Klänge, der andere nicht.
Also es fängt zum Beispiel einfach davon ab, was nehme ich für Loops zum Beispiel in meinen Ableton. Also im Ableton ist so ein Programm, mit dem du verschiedene Audioschleifen abspielen kannst. Ableton Live, genau zu sein.
Was hier übrigens auch gerade zum Einsatz kommt, aber es wird von mir eher vergewaltigt, hier als Lompa-Multtrack-Recorder.
Da siehst du ja, wie vielfältig das eigentlich ist. Und dann ist die Frage, lasse ich jetzt zum Beispiel einfach komplette Songs als Schleife abspielen und leg die übereinander, soll es welchen DJ? Und kann dann aber acht aufeinander legen zum Beispiel, ohne dass sie auseinanderlaufen? Oder nehme ich jetzt zum Beispiel immer nur zwei Beat Loops mit einem Klang und leg die übereinander? Oder schließe ich ein Keyboard an und spiele dann noch eine Synthesizer-Linie dazu? Also ist es dann immer sowohl ästhetisch getrieben, was mache ich eigentlich für Musik? Mach ich jetzt Musik, wo es auch Solos gibt? Oder mache ich Musik, die nur aus zwei Bass-Thumbs besteht? Und danach musst du dir auch immer überlegen, wie sehr beschränke ich mich, weil du dich live beschränken musst? Also auch beim Jazz übst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit, damit du live nicht mehr drüber nachdenken musst, was für eine Tonleiter, was für ein Song und so weiter kommt. Das muss alles unterbewusst laufen. Und diese Entwicklung passiert gerade bei der elektronischen Musik. Und jeder sich so ein bisschen zurechtlegt. Und bestimmte Sachen funktionieren gut, andere funktionieren nicht so gut. Aber das merkt man, also eins, das passiert gerade, weiß eigentlich noch nicht so jeder Bescheid. Und es kommen immer neue Instrumente auf den Markt. Und es ist interessant so auf jeden Fall. Und ich hab dann für mich jetzt meinen eigenen Weg gefunden und verfolge den jetzt, weil ich merke, das geht richtig tief. Und so wirklich viele in der Richtung machen es nicht, dass ich halt nur mit einem Drum-Computer versuche, so eine Klangqualität wie vom Platte und auch so eine Tiefe von der Klang-Ästhetik zum Beispiel auch zu erreichen, was schwer ist, wenn du zum Beispiel nicht die Möglichkeit hast, einfach vorproduzierte Sachen laufen zu lassen. Also ich muss, wenn ich nichts tue, dann wiederholt sich der letzte Takt einfach. Und beim Techno ist es halt nicht so, obwohl es so klingt, dass sich immer dasselbe läuft, ist eigentlich immer so eine totale Entwicklung irgendwie klanglich gegeben. Und diese Art zu spielen, irgendwann habe ich halt gesagt, mit dem Computer komme ich echt nicht zurecht, weil es klingt immer irgendwie unspannend. Und wenn ich dasselbe Set dann zweimal spiele, dann klingt es gleich. Und dann langweile ich mich auch. Und dann frage ich mich, was ich hier überhaupt auf der Bühne tue. Wie du es ja nachher zurechtlegst und so, wie ich das jetzt mache, wo ich echt dauernd am Schrauben und am Rotieren bin, das gefällt mir ganz gut so.
Das heißt, das ist auch eine Frage des User Interfaces eigentlich an der Stelle.
Auf jeden Fall.
Du sagst, mit dem Computer, also die Musik kommt am Ende immer noch aus dem Computer. Du hast deine Klänge, deine Samples, dein Arrangement. Das liegt im Rechner vor.
Ja, und gerade live, also Ableton Live, hat dann auch seine ganz eigene Art, dir das dann rüberzubringen. Und da gibt es dann auch wieder vollkommen andere Ansätze. Aber es ist total breit so. Also wenn du ein herkömmliche Instrument nimmst, auch ein Klavier, dann drückst du auf den Tasten, da kommt ein Klang raus. Und viel mehr ist es eigentlich nicht. Und beim Computer kannst du sagen, ich drücke auf K, dann passiert halt das. Oder ich drücke auf K, dann geht der Ton aus. Oder ich drücke auf K, dann geht der Delay auf. Das kannst du dir alles zurechtlegen. Und viele dieser Möglichkeiten sind vielleicht auch nicht so spannend, wie sie erst mal erscheinen. Es ist immer so ein sehr komischer Grad, wie das laufen soll.
Wo ich jetzt darauf hinaus wollte, gibt es ja schon seit längerem... Na, ich fange mal anders an. Wenn ich so zurückdenke, wie ich so vor... Wann fing das so an? Na ja, ich würde sagen so vor 15, 20 Jahren. Wie sich das so abgezeichnet hat mit den Computern. Also die Leute, die ja von Anfang an so ein bisschen tiefer drin stecken, für die war ja irgendwie klar, mehr oder weniger wird irgendwie alles in den Computer hineinmigrieren. Und es gibt da verschiedene Dinge, die sind geradezu prälistiniert, dort zu landen. Und Musik gehört definitiv dazu. Die CD war ja schon da, also digitale Musik in dem Sinne war schon geboren. Dass das Ganze irgendwann auf der Festplatte landet, das war dann irgendwie ein No-Brain-er in der Musiktechnik. Hat sich ja dann auch schnell der Sampler entwickelt, der das dann gemacht hat.
Oder die digitale Soundverarbeitung, sodass du dann nicht mehr...
Genau und so weiter. Und für mich war das irgendwie absehbar, dass dann in dem Moment, wo die Rechner dann einfach genug Saft haben, um dann sowieso auch alles in sich aufzunehmen, dass die Diversifikation an der Stelle dann eigentlich nur noch sein kann. Einerseits natürlich das User-Interface, aber andererseits auch die Möglichkeit der Programmierung, also eine Flexibilität dadurch reinzubringen, dass man eben nicht mehr so linearen Bedienungsfolgen da nur gehorcht, sondern dass man eben auch anfängt, das Ganze umzusetzen. Interessanterweise hat es in meiner Wahrnehmung vor allem erst mal das grafische Feld erobert, wenn man sich anschaut, was halt algorithmische Grafik so hervorgebracht hat über die Zeit. Ich meine, es fing so an mit Apfelmännchen, nicht wahr? Das ist ja im Prinzip schon mal so diese Verknüpfung von Mathematik und Visualisierung, da ist ja eine ganze Menge bei rausgekommen. Und wenn man sich heute so Screensaver anschaut, die dann irgendwie zur Musik rumhopsen, das ist ja eigentlich im Prinzip so was Ähnliches. Du hast aber jetzt was anderes gemacht. Du machst halt Musik, aber deine, was dich jetzt sozusagen zum konkreten Musik, wie soll man das sagen eigentlich, Musikgeräte, vielleicht nicht die richtige Bezeichnung, Musikcontroller, Musiksteuerungsgeräte.
Ich kann dir mal einfach erklären, wie dieser Controller, dieses kleine Gerät, was ich baue, was es macht und wie es überhaupt entstanden ist.
Genau, das muss man überhaupt erstmal, da ruf halt ich gerade hinaus. Also du hast irgendwann mal dir ein Gerät gebaut, warum?
Also ich hatte mal, als ich angefangen habe, habe ich Ableton Live benutzt, um Musik zu machen und da merkt man relativ schnell, dass das Interface vom Computer nicht gedacht ist, Musik zu spielen. Also du hast halt eine Tastatur, hast eine Maus und hast ein Display und im Endeffekt so wirklich passend ist es nicht auf der Tastatur, kannst du vielleicht ein bisschen drauf rumtippen, aber du kannst nicht wie beim Klavier halt leiser lauter zum Beispiel machen. Und deswegen werden oft eben zusätzliche Geräte an den Computer angeschlossen, die dann mit Fadern, mit Drehreglern und so weiter, die dir ermöglichen, die Lautstärke einzustellen, ohne jetzt die Maus zu nehmen, weil die Maus ruckelt und du kannst nur ein Parameter mit der Maus gleichzeitig ändern. Und das erste, was ich mir mal gebaut habe in meinem Elektronikfieber, war ein riesiger MIDI-Controller mit 48 Pottys und 1000 Tasten und alles so in einer riesigen großen Holzküste drin und dann auch schnell gemerkt, so bei jedem Gig gehen halt drei Pottys mehr kaputt und ich muss mir jedes Mal überlegen, wie ich das umsetze, aber es war so der erste Ansatz irgendwie.
Also du wolltest im Prinzip Total Control haben?
Ich wollte Total Control haben und es ist auch immer eine Gefahr, wenn du halt programmieren kannst und Musik machst, dass du immer ein bisschen zu weit denkst. Und also es war der erste Versuch, den habe ich irgendwie drei Mal live benutzt und dann gesagt, na das ist auch total bescheuert irgendwie, erstens weil er immer kaputt geht und zweitens irgendwie kann ich mir auch gleich ein fertiges kaufen, das ist dann genau so gut zu benutzen und ist halt stabiler und ist eh billiger. Und aber trotzdem war ich irgendwie ein bisschen unzufrieden, weil ich halt programmieren wollte. Bin ich dann zu anderen Software-Sachen rübergegangen, wie Reaktor zum Beispiel oder Max, wo du so in einer gewissen Art programmieren kannst. Du kannst so Dataflow-Programmierung machen, dass du halt eine Soundquelle an einen Filter anschließt und dann hier einen Mixer und dann hier noch einen kleinen Sequencer anschließt. War aber auch immer ziemlich unglücklich, weil diese Systemprogrammierung, diese symbolische, logische Programmierung, da eigentlich total ätzend zu implementieren ist. Also so einfach Copy-Paste im Sequencer zu bauen, ein Reaktor, da rupst du dir die Haare aus und eigentlich ist das eine Vorschleife, die einfach nur Werte kopiert. Und das kannst du grafisch oder mit dieser Musikprogrammiersoftware, die es gibt, nur gering machen. Und da gibt es andere Software zur Musik machen, die wirklich eine Programmiersprache ist, so Chuck oder Supercollider. Und die sind auch wieder auf der anderen Seite total ätzend, weil einfach nur um eine Sinuswelle rauszugeben, musst du halt irgendwie numerische Werte eingeben. Wo du eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt die Böcke drauf hast, wenn du jetzt einfach nur Beats machen willst zum Beispiel.
Was ist das nochmal kurz nachgefragt, Chuck und Supercollider?
Chuck ist so eine Programmiersprache. Ich hab's nur ganz kurz angeguckt, wo du parallel halt Prozesse laufen lassen kannst, die irgendwelche Sounds erzeugen und sich gegenseitig modulieren. Und Supercollider ist auch so eine relativ alte, die dann weitergewachsen ist. Aber wo du halt wirklich Text schreibst und nicht jetzt Kästchen zusammenbindest.
Aber im Prinzip sind das im Prinzip schon genau diese Ideen, dass man halt Musik programmiert.
Ja, nur das, wenn du halt nachher, weil mein Anliegen auch immer war, ein bisschen Party zu machen mit der Musik. Und die Leute sollen dazu tanzen. Mit Chuck kriegst du dann erst mal irgendwie so Ryohi-Kader-Sounds hin, die halt so......machen. Also so nicht unbedingt das, was mich gepackt hat.
Also mehr so für Effekte eigentlich?
Na, mehr so experimentell. Und wenn du anfängst, dann so algorithmische Strukturen für deine Musik zurechtzulegen, dann merkst du auch schnell, na, irgendwie weiß der Mensch schon genauer Bescheid, was ihn packt als der Computer. Also und was ist es, wenn irgendwelche Algorithmen laufen lässt und das kann entweder total cool klingen, es kann auch total scheiße klingen. Und so richtig Bescheid weiß der Computer nicht und wenn du einen Algorithmus entwürfst, weiß es auch nicht wirklich, was da, weißt du, weil die Regeln einfach auch auf Fehlern basieren, so dass einfach die coolsten Sachen auch immer bei Fehlern passieren. Ja und irgendwann habe ich gesagt, na, das mit dem Computer bringt alles nichts. Habe mir so einen Träumencomputer gekauft, der echt ganz schön teuer war von Electron, heißt Maschinenwurm, weil irgendwie hatte ich den Eindruck, okay, damit bin ich flexibel genug, das zu machen, was ich will und habe den so erstmal geholt und versucht, den Computer anzuschließen, gemerkt, irgendwie sind das zwei Welten, die aufeinander treffen. Das ist ja auch so eins der Dinge mit dem Computer, irgendwie, da läuft ja irgendwie eh deine ganze digitale Welt mit und stört, dass dann irgendwelche Treiber dann plötzlich nicht mehr funktionieren oder das was weiß ich oder du hast Latenzen und dein USB funktioniert nicht so, wie du es haben willst und das kannst du ja bestimmt alles in dich...
Das kenne ich, das hatte ich schon schwer am nicken, ja.
Und so gerade wenn du dann in Clubs spielst, willst du dich eigentlich nicht 10 Minuten vor dem Gig damit befassen, wo jetzt gerade dein Soundkartentreiber hingegangen ist, sondern du willst auf die Bühne gehen und irgendwie noch kurz einschalten und kurz noch entspannen, bevor es losgeht. Und dann habe ich irgendwann mal gesagt, ok ich mache jetzt meine Musik nur noch mit diesem Einsynthesizer, den schleppe ich an, den schalte ich an, tu die zwei Audio-Kabel rein, fertig. Das ist so das, was ich brauche und das habe ich dann angefangen.
Ganz ohne Live und ganz ohne...
Ganz ohne Live, ganz ohne anderes. Da hast du nur ein kleines Text-Display und du kannst nichts anderes machen als Musik. Aber dafür hast du auch 16 Knöpfe, die für die 16 Tracks da sind, hast 8 Regler, die für die 8 Parameter da sind und ist alles genauso konzipiert, wie du es mehr geht nicht und weniger geht auch nicht und so. Und gerade bei dem Drum-Synthesizer ist die GUI ziemlich gut gemacht, weil du kannst dann auch Synthesizer haben, wo die bessere Klänge haben, aber wo die Kontrollmöglichkeiten dir nicht so die Kreativität vermitteln und auch ermöglichen, die du selber hast. Dann hab ich angefangen mit diesem Drum-Computer irgendwie zu spielen und hab mir irgendwann mal kurz vorm Gig gedacht, irgendwie wärs ganz cool, wenn du noch vier Portis dazu hättest, um den Delay zu steuern. Weil du sonst auf dem Drum-Computer halt GUI-mäßig immer in so ein Untermenü gehen musst und da kannst du den Delay steuern.
Das heißt, die Features, die dir jetzt besonders wichtig waren und von denen du der Meinung warst, dass du eigentlich im Wesentlichen darüber deine Musik schnell und interaktiv beeinflussen möchtest, die waren nun rein zufällig bei diesem ansonsten ganz brauchbaren Gerät an einer Stelle versteckt, die einfach diesem direkten Einfluss sich entzogen.
Das war, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie ich auf die Idee kam, aber ich hab gesagt, das wäre mal ganz cool, das auszuprobieren. Ich glaub, da hatte ich auch grad Bock, wieder mal ein bisschen zu löten und hab halt für den Gig einfach gesagt, ich probier es mal einfach aus, mit dem Delay hier über vier Pottys zu steuern, das sind irgendwie 30 Zeilen C, weißt du, und mach's einfach mal so. Und dann hab ich das gebaut und war dann aber selber erstaunt plötzlich durch diese einfache Veränderung, dass ich den Delay separat habe, kann ich dann zum Beispiel so Sachen machen, wie den Feedback über 100 Prozent zu schalten.
Delay von was? Was wird verzögert?
Achso, genau, ich erklär mal. Also die Drum-Maschine hat 16 Spuren, die Klänge erzeugen und noch eine Effekt-Section, die dir dann Hall-Effekte bieten oder Delay-Effekte. Also der Klang sich immer wiederholt.
Drum-Maschine ist einfach so ein Gerät, das macht einfach so...
Das macht boom boom so.
Macht einfach boom boom so, der Kern boom boom drauf.
Kannst so zwei Takte einprogrammieren und dann machst boom boom und hast dann nachher die Möglichkeit, die Klänge zu verändern und verschieden zu setzen, die dir dann... Entweder kannst du Techno mitmachen oder Drum-Bass oder was auch, oder experimentelle Sachen und so. Und die Maschine ist so schon ganz schön konzipiert, dass die echt ganz schön flexibel ist. Ich meine, das Techno ist ja aus solchen Kisten entstanden, die kleine Loops wiederholt haben. Deswegen klingt Techno auch so und deswegen passt das besonders gut so, dass du halt Eintaktmusik machst mit einer Bassdrum, die sich immer wiederholt. Aber diese Möglichkeit, dann diesen Delay separat zu haben, hat dann zum Beispiel bedeutet...
Also was wird jetzt delayed?
Kannst sagen, ich habe einen Chordklang und der macht dann irgendwie anstatt nicht nur Büm, macht halt Büm, Büm, Büm, Büm. Das kannst du immer einstellen, kannst halt immer so einen Send in den Delay reinstellen, dass es der Klang jetzt auch in Hall drauf gelegt kriegt.
Okay, Hall.
Ich weiß nicht, heißt das auf Deutsch Hall? Also Hall ist ja eigentlich Reverb, ne? Echo. Ein Echo-Effekt ist das.
Weil das Delay ist ja einfach erstmal nur eine Verzögerung. Ich dachte jetzt, dass einfach dann die Taktik später kommt oder so.
Also nee, das heißt dann, das ist ja Delay, weil so eine Verzögerungslinie drin ist, die den Sound aufnimmt und dann nochmal loopt so. Und dadurch hatte ich dann plötzlich die Möglichkeit, den Feedback höher zu stellen, dass der Klang halt nicht immer leiser wird und irgendwann mal verschwindet, sondern immer lauter wird. Und ich weiß, wenn das anfängt zu laut zu werden, brauche ich nicht in dieses Untermenü zu gehen, sondern kann einfach den Regler nach unten drehen. Dadurch habe ich angefangen, immer so ein bisschen rumzuspielen und dann plötzlich gemerkt, jetzt kann ich mit diesem Effekt plötzlich Flächen bauen, ich kann kleine komische Geräusche bauen, ich kann Polirhythmen bauen, dass mir eigentlich nur dadurch möglich wurde, dass ich halt diese vier zusätzlichen Regler hatte. Aber das war mir vorher eigentlich nicht wirklich klar, dass es geht. Und das hat sich dann so sehr in meiner eigenen Musik auch zum richtigen Instrument entwickelt, weil man den echt organisch schön immer bestimmen kann. Ich spiele dann nachher auch gleich so ein kleines Beispiel, wie sich das anhört, dass du dann richtig Spaß hast, du musst es auch ein bisschen üben, weil du kannst richtig schnell auch Scheiße bauen. Aber es hat sich dann zu so einem richtigen Instrument zusätzlich zu dem, der schon vorgegeben war, irgendwie entwickelt. Und das war dann, eigentlich spiele ich jetzt, wenn ich live bin, eigentlich oft am Delay rum. Weil ich es geübt habe, ich kann das jetzt immer ganz gut und weiß auch, wenn ich das Rad drehe, dann entwickelt sich das so und es klingt cool. Aber es war diese ganz kleine Veränderung irgendwie. Ich hatte nur vier Regler und dann habe ich das in so einem Forum gepostet und dann haben so ein paar Leute gesagt, na, baue mir auch mal einen, das klingt ziemlich cool. Und dadurch wurde es dann plötzlich immer professionell und dann habe ich gesagt, das bringt jetzt gar nichts, so zehn Unikate da irgendwie mühsam herzustellen, sondern mach mal gleich irgendwie eine Firma draus.
Wenn du am Rad drehst, dann klingt das cool, ja, das kenne ich auch. Aber ich kenne mal... So, um das nochmal so technisch kurz bevor, du hast jetzt ein paar Beispiele oder was?
Ich mache einfach so ein Beispiel von so einem Live-Set, wo man auch hört, was für Flächen man im Deal-Mode zum Beispiel.
Ja, okay, mach mal, spiel mal ein. Jetzt gibt es hier mal ein bisschen Begleitmusik.
Genau, das ist jetzt so eine Probeaufnahme und irgendwann kommt auch der Echo so zu tragen.
Bitteschön, der Herr.
Es sind zwei Synthesizer, insgesamt 22 Spuren, aber es müssten jetzt eigentlich zwei laufen, glaube ich. Also eine wieder aufgenommen vom Rest. Die Hi-Hat hört man, jetzt kommt der Sub rein. Und ich kann mal vielleicht ein bisschen vorscrollen, weil kommt irgendwann so ein Delay-Org hier in der Mitte. Jetzt hört man den Delay zum Beispiel. Genau, es wiederholt sich immer und wächst dann an und dann verschwindet jetzt so langsam. Das sind alles Sachen, die ich dann live eindrehe. Wenn ich nichts mache, wiederholt sich das einfach ohne Veränderung. Man merkt, jetzt geht er so langsam weg und es ist eigentlich nur noch so als Noise da, aber er trägt zur allgemeinen Dichte des Klangs irgendwie bei. Und dann kannst du natürlich auch ziemlich extrem benutzen, jetzt kommt er auch wieder und wird dann enorm wachsen. Das war jetzt der erste Anfang, wo ich gemerkt habe, anstatt jetzt 48 Felder zu nehmen und damit irgendwas zu steuern, vier reichen eigentlich, wenn die vier das bringen. Weil du hast ja eh nur zwei Hände, du kannst eigentlich nur an zwei Knöpfen drehen. Dass du dann, wenn du dir das genau überlegst oder nicht genau überlegst, aber auch viel ausprobierst, dann bleiben so ein paar Sachen hängen, die diese Tiefe von dieser Delay-Steuerung hatten. Und da kam dann irgendwie das ganze Technische wieder zu tragen, weil eigentlich kannst du... Jetzt geh ich mal vielleicht auch auf MIDI ein, was eigentlich MIDI als Protokoll ist.
Das ist das technische in dir sozusagen kam wieder zu tragen.
Genau, also der Hacker, der früher Künstler geöffnet hat.
Genau, der Hacker, der sozusagen on hold war, ja genau, darauf wollte ich jetzt auszusprechen kommen. Also kurz gesagt, du hast Musik entdeckt oder wiederentdeckt, hast dich dann da irgendwie reingesteigert, hast dann aber irgendwann, bist du so ein bisschen an den User-Interfaces verreckt, das kenne ich ja auch aus meinen ganzen Podcast-Experimenten nur zu gut. Und hast dann einfach, ja quasi eigentlich dein eigenes User-Interface gebraucht, wenn man es mal ganz simpel nimmt, das User-Interface, um an der Stelle in diesen Geräten Einfluss zu nehmen, die diese Geräte so selber erst mal gar nicht vorgesehen haben. Also sie vorgesehen haben, weil es ist ja steuerbar, aber eben nur über MIDI, nur dafür gibt es halt nicht den passenden Regler oder die passende Tasse, die in dem Moment angemessen wäre. Das heißt, du hast ein Gerät gebaut, was im Prinzip eigentlich nix anderes ist als ein MIDI-Controller. Davon gibt es ja viele.
Da gibt es vielernd da mehr irgendwie, aber es kommt dann darauf an, also viele kannst du auch echt extrem konfigurieren und mit Spezialfunktionen besetzen und so weiter. Aber im Endeffekt ist das erstens eine Komplexität an sich und es wird nie genau unbedingt deine Konzepte, die du gerade verfolgst oder sowas, erreichen. Dieses Ding, dass du diese statische Konfiguration hast, welcher Knopf sendet, welchen Parameter, je nach Controller kannst du dann auch noch so Sachen machen, dass er sich halt in die umgekehrte Richtung bewegt oder nur in bestimmten Range irgendwie erreicht. Das sind aber schon so die Advanced-Controller. Aber du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, wenn ich den Fader bewege, dann bewegt er den Parameter so rum und den anderen bewegt er irgendwie in Inkrements von drei zum Beispiel. Also eigentlich so ganz total einfache Überlegungen, die aber nicht zu machen sind, es sei denn, du nimmst wieder deinen Computer und schreibst dir dann einen Max-Patch oder irgendwie ein Programm. Da hast du aber wieder die Problematik, dass du Latenz hast, einen Computer und du musst deine eigene Software starten und alles total anstrengend, gerade wenn du auf Tour bist. Aber im Endeffekt ist ja so ein Controller auch nur ein Computer, so ein kleiner, ne? Und auch nicht besonders schwer zu programmieren im Endeffekt. Also es gibt da schon haarige Details, aber für viele Sachen total easy. Also gerade zum Beispiel so Sachen, ich hab das auf der Dwarven-Maschine, ich kann Samples abspielen und benutze das auch, um immer wieder den letzten Loop aufzunehmen und der ist dann einen Tag lang. Und ich kann den Startpunkt von dem Sample, wo er anfängt zu spielen, einstellen. Das heißt, wenn ich ihn auf Null setze, dann fängt er am Anfang an. Wenn ich auf 64 setze, fängt er in der Mitte an. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel den Startpunkt größer setze als den Endpunkt, dann läuft der Sample rückwärts zum Beispiel. Und das kannst du ja natürlich benutzen, um dein Sample kleine Stücke zu zerschneiden, sodass er nur noch eine Viertelnote davon wiederholt. Aber das kannst du live nicht machen, weil du das halt nie hinkriegst, im Tempo die Knöpfe auf 32 zu drehen und dann wieder auf 64. Das kriegst du einfach mechanisch nicht hin.
Das heißt, an der Stelle ist Software vernöten. An der Stelle brauchst du etwas, was sozusagen genau das tut, was du willst, aber du steuerst es nicht manuell, außer dass du vielleicht eine Tasse drückst, um das sozusagen zu starten, aber eigentlich startest du ein Programm.
Ja, genau, ich hab jetzt gerade diese Sample zerschnallen, hab ich halt einen Knopf auf meinem Controller, dann stell ich eine Viertelnote und dann weiß ich, der letzte Loop läuft jetzt auf Viertelnoten gesyncht.
Also das ist jetzt sozusagen auch das Besondere an deinem Controller und an deinem Ansatz und jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, einer der Gründe, warum wir da jetzt überhaupt drüber reden. Dieses Gerät ist jetzt nicht einfach nur ein weiterer MIDI-Taster und ich drück auf eine Taste und dann kommt eine MIDI-Note, dann drückst du auf eine Taste und dann läuft in deine Software, die dann über MIDI ein komplexeres Makro abspielt sozusagen, vielleicht auch noch in Abhängigkeiten von anderen Reglerstellungen, die dann eben das tun. Das heißt, der eigentliche Effekt, den du einbringst, in dem du Parameter in Echtzeit beeinflusst, ist selbst programmiert, ist vorprogrammiert, ist parametrisierbar für sich.
Ja, ohne ist Touring mächtig eigentlich so, dass du halt IF-Dinger reintun kannst, vorschleifen, dass ich auch relativ einfach sagen kann, wenn ich den gehalten habe und den gehalten habe und dann drauf drücke, dann passiert das, was auf einem normalen Controller, obwohl er auch Taster hat und so, kannst du nicht sagen, wenn ich den drücke und den drücke und dann den Fader bewege, dann passiert das oder wenn ich den drücke, dann kommt halt ein spezielles Menü, was halt Hallo Manuel sagt oder sowas, je nachdem, was du dir... Aber kompliziert, wenn du programmieren kannst, ist das ja eigentlich gar nicht. Und oft regst du dich auch auf, wo du sagst, hätte ich nur die Möglichkeit, den Knopf zu invertieren. Weil die Hardware ist ja da und der Chip ist ja meistens auch stark genug, dass er so abkann. Also es gibt eigentlich nur die einzige Beschränkung, die du hast, dass du nicht wirklich eingreifen kannst in das System. Deswegen ist er jetzt auch, mein eigener jetzt auch Open Source, damit andere Leute die Möglichkeit haben, das zu... so zu gestalten, wie sie wollen. Aber es ist dieser zwingende Punkt, dass eigentlich nur ganz, ganz kleine Details einen riesen Unterschied machen.
Das Gerät klingt jetzt natürlich sehr mächtig, hat aber tatsächlich nur wenig Knöpfer. Das sind nur wie paar Tasten, paar Regler.
Ja, vier Encoder sind das, vier Taster, die Encoder kann man auch noch als Taster benutzen.
Also Encoder, Drehregler.
Encoder sind Drehregler, die unendlich gehen.
Die aber auch selber noch als Taste benutzbar sind, so dass man sie zuschalten kann.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel so Features, das habe ich mir abgeguckt, dass wenn man am Encoder dreht, hat so 30 Details pro Umdrehung, das heißt, eigentlich kannst du mit einer Umdrehung so von 0 auf 30 gehen. Wenn du den halt gedrückt hast und drehst, dann springt er in 5er-Inkrementen, das heißt, du kannst mit einer Umdrehung von voll auf maximal gehen. Was so ganz kleine Details sind, aber wenn du die nicht hast, ist es einfach ein Weltunterschied, weil du sonst immer 5 Sekunden lang drehen musst, um auf 127 zu kommen und das ist im Techno dann nicht mehr zu gebrauchen.
Dann hast du noch ein paar Tasten?
Ja, 4 Tasten. Ich hab 2 MIDI-Inputs, 1 MIDI-Output. Das waren auch so ein bisschen technische Constraints, weil halt nicht mehr reingepasst ist, reingepasst hat, aber solche Sachen ermöglichen dir dann auch, MIDI-Filter zu bauen. Ich hab einen zweiten Input, alles, was da rüberkommt, kann ich zum Beispiel transponieren. Also ein Feature, was echt ziemlich cool ist, die Drummaschine hat ganz viele Drumklänge, weil die ja auch ein Drumcomputer ist. Also du hast eine Bass-Drum oder du hast irgendwie eine Snare. Und wenn du so ein bisschen an der Snare rumdrehst, dann klingt die irgendwie wie eine Blockflöte, aus welchem Grund auch immer. Aber du kannst auch verschiedene Tonhöhen spielen, alle musst halt echt wissen. So ein C ist halt Tonhöhe 64 und ein D ist Tonhöhe 58 und das heißt, das kannst du live nicht eindeilen. Auch wenn du es dann im Studio versuchst, eine Melodie einzugeben auf der Snare, hast du halt so eine Tabelle an der Wand, da habe ich dann immer abgeguckt. Aha, okay, jetzt drehe ich das auf 32 auf dem Step, auf dem nächsten auf 44 und da brauchst du einfach irgendwie eine halbe Stunde, um eine Melodie einzugeben. Und wenn die Melodie dann noch scheiße ist, dann sagst du, jetzt lasse ich mir lieber. Und was der Controller jetzt macht, der liest dann die Einstellung von der Drum-Machine ein, erkennt dann, da ist eine Snare auf Track 2, wenn jetzt eine Note vom Keyboard auf dem zweiten Input kommt, gucke ich in meiner kleinen Lookup-Tabelle und schicke gleich einen richtigen Pitch raus. Das heißt, ich schließe einfach ein Keyboard an und kann die Snare einfach so spielen. Die ganzen Möglichkeiten sind ja da, die Snare kann ich pitchen. Aber ob ich jetzt meine Snare live spielen kann oder ob ich da eine halbe Stunde für zwei Takte verbrauche, das ist einfach nur eine Lookup-Tabelle, was eigentlich auch programmiertechnisch nicht wirklich was Komplizierendes ist.
Also im Prinzip ist das Gerät so deine Klangvorstellungen und deine Klangbeeinflussungsvorstellungen in Silizium gegossen bzw. in Pitches und Bites, die dann halt darauf zum Einsatz kommen. Das heißt, das Ding ist programmierbar, das Ding ist reprogrammierbar, das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie fest, das ist im Prinzip ein kleiner Computer, Mikrocontroller, basiert. Was steckt da so drin im Wesentlichen?
Da ist so ein kleiner Atmel 8-Bit-Controller drin, so ein Atmega64, der hat dann noch bis, also der läuft mit 16 MHz echt so ein total langsames Teil eigentlich. Den habe ich dann noch mit ein bisschen externen RAM versorgt, weil 4 Kilobyte dann doch ein bisschen zu hart sind. Also gerade, wenn du mit größeren MIDI-Nachrichten zum Beispiel arbeitest.
Also 4 Kilobyte, das ist irgendwas, das sozusagen der Prozessor onboard mitbringt.
Genau, und der hat noch 64 dazu, dann ist noch eine Mikro-SD.
Das kriegt man ja nie voll, irgendwie 64. Nee, nee, das kriege ich nicht voll.
Das kriege ich auch echt nicht voll. Was ich relativ schnell vollkriege, ist der Program-Space. Aber das liegt am Compiler, der ist ganz böse. Aber auf jeden Fall eine ziemlich beschränkte Plattform, hat auch nur so ein Text-Display.
Aber im Prinzip ist das so ein C64. So von der Dimensionierung her. Das ist nicht dieselbe Technologie, aber ich weiß nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist er schneller als ein C64, oder?
Ich denke, ein bisschen geringfügiger. Aber so im Endeffekt ist es dann...
So, so deine Tasten, das Ganze ist irgendwie in recht stabile Hardware eingegossen.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Kriterium.
Und das ist halt irgendwie dein Teil.
Und das kannst du dann am Computer anschließen. Da hab ich so eine kleine Software, wenn du nur User bist. Weil viele Musiker können halt nicht programmieren. Ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass es einfach ist, das Ding zu programmieren. Man muss halt schon ein bisschen wissen, was du machst.
Klar. Ich wollte jetzt mal so ein bisschen mehr darauf hinaus, wie... Gut, also ich meine, dein eigenes Gerät zu haben und dass das MIDI spricht. Ich denke, das war dann ab dem Moment, wo du sagst, ich will selber beeinflussen, war das irgendwie klar. Das ist sozusagen die Konsequenz. Das User Interface von dem Gerät taugt nicht. Du willst was zum Anfassen haben. Also musst du dieses zum Anfassen auch selber bauen.
Das war auch gar nicht mal dieses taugt nicht, sondern einfach, ich will auch ein bisschen zusätzlich ausprobieren.
Also taugt für dich, also reicht dir nicht. Das war nicht das. Nicht schlecht, sondern ist für dich halt nicht genug gewesen. Deswegen brauchst du da dein eigenes Ding. Jetzt ist ja so, du hast ja, so wie du es erzählt hast, vor allem auch ein Software-Hintergrund. Das heißt, Hardware war für dich dann auch was ein bisschen Learning by doing an der Stelle?
Ja, also ich hatte schon Embedded-Programmierung gemacht. Und ein paar Boards. Also als ich den Controller angefangen habe, da habe ich schon ein bisschen mehr Hardware-Erfahrung gehabt. Aber nichts so mit Geräte bauen. Ich habe immer so Schaltpläne für externe Firmen gebaut, so USB-Boards und so Zeugs. Aber jetzt nicht wie baue ich ein Gerät, was halt unter Strobulicht dann mit einem Glas Wodka daneben so die Nacht aushält. Das ist auch bei vielen Kontrollern auch so ein Problem, dass sie halt aus Plastik sind und dann die ganzen Strapazzen nicht überleben. Aber das war alles so ein bisschen Learning by doing. Das war auch eine ganz schön harte Zeit, muss ich sagen. Also erstens die ersten Prototypen zu bauen, dann habe ich auch so zehn kleine Geräte, Prototypen verschickt und dann auch gemerkt, na eigentlich kannst du das nicht verkaufen, weil das alles so krumm und irgendwie mit dem Handbohrer gemacht ist. Und diese Industrialisierung, das war schon ein ganz schöner harter Schritt im letzten Jahr.
Es gab ja auch schon mal ein Chaosradio Express zum Thema Microcontroller, wo wir dann so ähnliche Themen auch tangiert haben. Chaosradio Express 67 war das mit FT0, da haben wir auch viel über so Atmel, AVR und so weiter gesprochen, das ist im Prinzip der selbe Ansatz, den du hier auch gemacht hast, plus mit einer anderen Ausrichtung. Bei ihm ging es dann vor allem so ein bisschen um Licht und so, machen andere Sachen, aber weniger jetzt um MIDI. Trotzdem so MIDI ist ja dann auch erstmal nicht ohne Komplexität, das muss ja dann auch erstmal irgendwie alles richtig implementiert und gebaut werden. Hast du dich an irgendwelchen Bausätzen orientiert?
Na MIDI, von der Elektronik her ist es relativ einfach, weil es einfach nur eine serielle Schnittstelle ist. Es ist zwar ein Stromkreis, das heißt, du brauchst so ein kleiner Chip, der Optokoppler heißt, um diesen Strom wieder eine Spannung umzusetzen, aber im Endeffekt nimmst du deinen Atmel, schließt dir zwei Kabel an, dann hast du MIDI und setzt die serielle Schnittstelle auf 31.250 Boards. Das heißt, auch von Auslesen usw. ist es eigentlich nur serielle Schnittstelle, was immer total Nummer 2 ist beim Mikrocontroller. Was dann ein bisschen komplizierter ist, ist erstens, die MIDI-Nachrichten zu pasen, weil es so ein binäres Protokoll ist mit den 80ern Entworfen. Also es ist dann auch in vielen Hardware-Synthesizers eh schon dabei. Eigentlich alle, die seit den 80ern gebaut werden, ist eh immer MIDI dabei. Deswegen ist es auch so eine de facto Standard-Schnittstelle geworden, dass auch immer noch die neuen Geräte so ein bisschen klobiges, langsames Interface drin haben. Und die Schwierigkeiten sind dann eher, also erstens, wie pas ich das richtig, weil da gibt es schon so ein paar Hintertüren, die nicht unbedingt gleich ersichtlich sind. Du hast so Sachen wie Running-Status, damit es weniger Platz verbraucht. Und dann gibt es Realtime-Nachrichten, die immer dazwischen funken, dann hast du CIS-X-Nachrichten, die so längere, binäre Blobs sind, die darüber gehen. Das musst du erstmal alles so ein bisschen pasen, und das ist nicht ganz ohne. Und dann hast du aber nachher so die komplizierte Seite, immer so Sync ist immer so ein bisschen das Leitthema bei generell, wenn du elektronische Musik machst, mit mehr als einer Kiste. Dass du eine genaue Clock haben musst, beim Techno ist es dann besonders fies, weil du eigentlich, so wie wenn zwei Platten auseinanderlaufen, hörst du es sofort, wenn die Baseball ein bisschen zu spät kommt, dann facet sie und verschwindet im Stereofeld und so alles.
Jetzt müssen wir glaube ich mal ein bisschen den Blickwinkel ändern. Klar ist, Musik beeinflussen will und so weiter, alles ist irgendwie MIDI. Jetzt hast du ja schon die ersten Schwierigkeiten dabei auch aufgezeigt.
Ja, so ein fieses technisches Ding.
Genau, jetzt ist MIDI natürlich auch so ein bisschen wie eine Technologie. Jeder kennt es irgendwie, keiner hat es sich ganz genau angeschaut. Vielleicht können wir ja da mal ein bisschen einen genaueren Blick darauf werfen, damit jetzt diese ganzen Sachen, die du jetzt hier so als naja, ist halt alles nicht so einfach, dass man die auch mal so ein bisschen versteht. Insbesondere jetzt im Hinblick darauf, dass wir hier mit diesem Gespräch auch so die Leute ansprechen wollen, die sich denken so, ich könnte das ja auch mal ein interessanter Ansatz und so MIDI beeinflussen. Muss ja gar nicht mal Audio sein, sondern man kann ja auch viele andere Sachen damit zu machen. Ich bin ja hier auch so ein bisschen am Überlegen, hier für mein Radiostudio, damit MIDI das eine oder andere zu automatisieren, beziehungsweise tue das auch schon, so mit so Kapitelgenerierung etc. Was umfasst MIDI und was muss man wissen, um das irgendwie zu verstehen? Also auf der physikalischen Ebene hast du es ja schon angesprochen. Vielleicht fangen wir damit mal an.
Ist es eine serielle Leitung im Duplex, das heißt, du hast eine Leitung zum Empfangen, eine Leitung zum Senden, die parallel laufen. Das sind auch zwei getrennte Kabel, also nicht so wie bei den seriellen Schnittstellen von Computern, wo du ein Kabel hast.
Dann geht es in beide Richtungen.
Dann hast du einen Nullmodell, einen Adapter reintun und so. Aber da hast du immer so ein getrenntes Kabel.
Das heißt, das Kabel hat immer eine Richtung. Es geht immer von, nach.
Genau, es geht von Out nach In. Das steht auch immer hinter jedem Synthesizer. Du hast meistens drei MIDI-Anschlüsse. Ein In, ein Out und ein Thru, der eigentlich nur so ein Mirror-Image von einem In ist. Und darüber laufen dann so kleine binäre Nachrichten. Also da hast du so Nachrichten wie zum Beispiel Spiel eine Note, der Ton hört C. Das ist dann so eine Note-On-Nachricht. Und die wird dann zum Beispiel von einer Note-Off-Nachricht gefolgt. Sagt, hör jetzt auf, die Note zu spielen.
Also Technik ist einfach eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Mit einem bestimmten Protokoll daneben.
Der Stacker ist dieser uralte 5-Politinen-Stecker.
Den 180 Grad, ja.
Genau, diese fetten Teile, die so den Vorteil haben, die stecken irgendwie auch ganz gut, wenn sie erst mal drin sind. Sehen so ein bisschen altertümlich aus, aber sonst hat ja noch mal was.
Die halten auch ordentlich was aus. Die haben den echt nervigen Nachteil, dass sie so hoch sind. Und wenn du Geräte baust, nervt das immer, dass du hinten so einen 3-cm-Stecker hast. Aber hat sich so eingebürgert, die MIDI-Kabel kriegst du auch überall so. Und das ist auch elektrisch ganz gut gemacht, dass du halt keine Grundschleifen hast zum Beispiel. Also kannst du deine Geräte in beliebige Steckdosen, Phasen stecken und die tun sich jetzt nicht die Masse dann teilen. Was live jetzt ziemlich praktisch ist. Aber nachher laufen da, es gibt da so eine ganze Klasse an verschiedenen Nachrichten, die eigentlich alle so einen musikalischen Hintergrund haben. Also diese Notennachrichten habe ich jetzt gerade erwähnt. Du hast Kontrollernachrichten, die einfach nur numerische Werte rausschicken. Also kannst sagen, ich habe einen Controller mit einer bestimmten Nummer von 0 bis 127 und der schickt Werte von 0 bis 127 raus. Das kannst du auf den Fader legen, dann bewegst du den Fader und dann kommen numerische Werte.
Oder halt deine Drehregler.
Oder Drehregler, oder kannst auch irgendwie einen Windcontroller nehmen, wo du reinbläst oder alles Mögliche eigentlich nehmen. Und diese Nachrichten können dann nachher auch wieder was anderes steuern. Und da ist der interessante Aspekt als Hacker, dass du sagst, das sind ja eh nur Bits und Bytes. Erstens kann ich da rumtricksen und irgendwie Bilder encoden zum Beispiel. Also die ganzen üblichen Tricks, die man kennt, gerade wenn man so exploits oder sowas schreibt, wo du dann sagst, im Endeffekt sind es eh nur Bytes. Und das dann so ein bisschen missbrauchen, was dann oft nicht unbedingt ersichtlich ist, weil dieses MIDI so stark strukturiert ist.
Aber bleiben wir nochmal ein bisschen bei MIDI und wie das so aufgebaut ist. Also was du ja schon gesagt hast, okay, wir haben eine seriöse Schnittstelle, das heißt da gehen da so Bytes rüber und bestimmte Gruppen von Bytes gelten als einzelne Nachricht. Das heißt, jede Nachricht ist auch so für sich abgeschlossen und ist sie zu Ende, dann beginnt danach wieder ein komplett neuer Kontext und man muss die Dinge selber dann sozusagen interpretieren, wenn dann eben mehrere Sachen kommen, die sich auf das gleiche beziehen. Klassische Nachricht ist halt Note an, Note aus. Man muss sich das auch vorstellen, das ist so diese Zeit gewesen, da stand man so mit dem Keyboard auf der Bühne, dann ging dann so ein MIDI-Kabel zum Synthesizer, der halt die Töne erzeugt. Das heißt, das Keyboard macht eigentlich nichts anderes als Tastendruck zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Und wenn ich halt auf so eine Taste draufdrücke, dann schickt das Gerät das erste Mal schon eine Nachricht raus, nämlich diese Taste wurde jetzt gedrückt, beziehungsweise ist gerade gedrückt.
Mit der Anschlaggeschwindigkeit so und so, damit auch noch ein bisschen mehr runterkommt.
Dass es einen Unterschied macht, ob ich da einfach nur so sanft draufdrücke oder ob ich richtig drauf haue. Das kann ja für den Ton dann schon sehr entscheidend sein. Und wenn ich sie wieder loslasse, gibt es nochmal eine Nachricht. Das ist dann Note Off, das heißt, wurde losgelassen.
Damit kann der Synthesizer dann den Klang irgendwie abschneiden oder langsam ausklingen lassen. Aber eigentlich kann das dann offen so.
Genau, dann gibt es aber auch noch die Möglichkeit, dass man die Tasten dann auch noch drückt, während man sie gedrückt hält.
Ja, da gibt es dann auch eine spezielle Nachricht dazu, die heißt dann Aftertouch. Da gibt es dann auch verschiedene Arten von Aftertouch, ob das jetzt ein globales ist für das komplette Keyboard oder ob es pro Taste ist. Da gibt es dann eigentlich so ganz viele kleine Untergliederungen, die je nach Synthesizer und je nach Keyboard oder wie auch immer irgendwie anders interpretiert werden. Da gibt es auch immer so eine Spezifikationstabelle am Ende, die so vorgegeben ist, wenn du MIDI unterstützen willst, dann musst du so eine Art Kreuzchen machen, ich unterstütze die Nachricht und du unterstützt die Nachricht.
Ja, das ist dann in meinem Handbuch immer hinten drin zu finden.
Genau, und ich glaube, was ein bisschen hinderlich ist bei MIDI, dass es so viele verschiedene Ansätze gibt oder nie wirklich klar ist, was es genau ist, ist, dass die Spezifikation nicht offen ist. Also es gibt zwar, du kannst jetzt zwar zusammenmogeln aus tausend verschiedenen Webseiten, aber die eigentliche MIDI-Referenz, die musst du immer noch kaufen. Für 50 Dollar kriegst du irgendwie so ein photokopiertes Spiralbuch. Und da steht es dann irgendwie dann doch genau drin, wie es auszusehen hat, um jetzt zu irgendwann, welche Nachrichten die anderen unterberichten. Da gibt es echt tausend kleine Feinheiten, weil die Leute dann auch gemerkt haben, naja, irgendwie ist es schon ein bisschen beschränkt so.
Ja gut, aber bleiben wir trotzdem nochmal so, ich würde gerne einfach mal so ein bisschen den Umfang umreißen, damit einfach mal so ein bisschen klar wird. Also jetzt erstmal so diese Reihen noch aus dem Keyboard, Zeitalter, ich meine, das Zeitalter gilt im Prinzip immer noch, aber von dieser konkretes Gerätdenke her, nicht wahr, die haben dann immer noch dieses Rad an der Seite, dieses Modulation Wheel und Pitch Wheel, dafür gibt es dann auch noch eigene Sachen. War es das eigentlich auch schon im Wesentlichen, was so Klang ist?
Nee, es gibt natürlich klangmäßig, ja es gibt dann, also danach kommen so die interessanten Nachrichten, sage ich mal, aber so was Klang angeht, fallen mir dann noch welche an.
Die interessanten Nachrichten.
Ja, die interessanten Nachrichten sind dann die ersten Stereo-Time-Nachrichten, ich überlege gerade, ob es noch klangmäßig welche gibt, aber ich glaube, die sind auch nicht unbedingt so spannend.
Ich habe hier so eine Liste, da steht noch so was wie Program und Channel-Pressure drauf, das habe ich nie gesehen.
Ja, Channel-Pressure ist dieses globale Aftertouch. Also du hast halt Keyboards, je nachdem wie das Keyboard gebaut ist, entweder hast du halt so einen Drucksensor unter jeder Tasse, was halt furchtbar teuer ist und ein bisschen unhandlich, oder du hast so einen Drucksensor, der über das komplette Keyboard geht. Weil ich kenne auch wenige Gitarristen, die so drei Finger drücken können, und dann noch von jedem Finger die Lautedecke modulieren können.
Also das heißt, man stellt einmal ein, alle Tassen, die ich jetzt drücke, sind so und so starke Tassen?
Nee, das ist einfach von der Elektronik her so. Das ist einfach so eine fette...
Okay, aber warum gibt es das noch mal als eigenes MIDI-Wind?
Weil es dann auch Controller gibt, die dann eben einzelne Tasten modulieren, also die Pressure dann abmessen können. Oder wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Wind-Controller hast oder was auch immer, kannst du dir eh auch immer zurechtlegen, was es jetzt wirklich bedeutet.
Na klar, na klar. Aber erstmal wollte ich davon ausgehen, was sich mal jemand dabei gedacht hat, das überhaupt einzuführen, weil es ist ja irgendwie da. Program, sehe ich ja auch gerade noch, was ist das?
Program-Change ist, wenn du jetzt verschiedene Klänge auf dem Synthesizer auswählen willst. Also Programme heißt es dann oder Presets oder so. Und dann sagst du jetzt schalt mal auf Trompetenklang und dann schickst du Program-Change 15. Was ganz wichtig ist, was wir nicht erwähnt haben, ist, dass die MIDI-Nachrichten noch Kanäle haben. Das heißt, du kannst 16 logische Kanäle sozusagen einstellen. Das ist eben der eine Synthesizer auf Kanal 1, ein anderer auf Kanal 2. Und die können sich dann dieselbe Leitung teilen. Und trotzdem triggert die Note halt den einen Synthesizer.
Beziehungsweise, wenn man zwei Keyboards hat, dann würde das eine Keyboard auf dem einen Kanal, das andere auf dem anderen. Und damit die halt einfach unterscheidbar sind. Weil am Ende sind sie ja topologisch, sind sie alle in einer Kette geschaltet.
Das ist eine Problematik für sich, so wie man MIDI-Geräte untereinander verknüpft. Es gibt natürlich dieses Voo, also dass du eigentlich das Inn einfach gemirrored wird. Elektrisch ist da einfach nur ein Puffer dazwischen, das kommt dann raus. Damit kannst du ein Keyboard, ein fähiges Synthesizer eigentlich anschließen. Da kommen die Noten bei jedem Synthesizer an. Damit kannst du zum Beispiel nicht mehrere Controller hintereinander ketten. Weil dann die Nachrichten vom ersten Controller aus dem zweiten rauskommen, aber vom zweiten nicht mehr. Dann musst du die merken. Bestimmte Controller können schon merken. Sonst gibt es so kleine Mercher-Kisten, wo du dann auch wieder gleich Bandbreitenprobleme hast und vielleicht sind die Kanäle falsch gesetzt. Das ist echt eine Thematik für sich auch. Das ist auch immer so eine gute Fehlerquelle, wo du auf der Bühne bist und irgendwie einen Mercher da hast und wenn der anfängt rumzuspinnen, dann raffst du erstmal gar nicht, was so passiert.
Dann gibt es ja noch so eine Kategorie von MIDI-Nachrichten, die sich dieses System-Common oder so...
Ja, System-Sechs-Nachrichten.
Nee, das ist noch was System-Exclusive. System-Common, was weiß ich, so Timecode, Songauswahl...
Die Realtime-Nachrichten.
Realtime ist nochmal die dritte Kategorie, glaube ich. Clock und so weiter.
Ja, also es gibt Nachrichten, wo du Sequencer starten und stoppen kannst. Sequencer können so kleine Songs abspielen oder im Takt halt mitlaufen, irgendwelche Sachen machen. Da hast du immer so Kommandos wie starte, stoppe, pause, spring zu der Stelle. Da gibt es auch eine ganze Klasse Nachrichten. Ich kenne die auch nie so ganz aus.
Okay, also das ist so ein Prinzip, diese Sachen, einmal das direkte Spielen, dann dieses Sequencer-artige Wähle, ein Lied aus und so weiter, dass man das auch automatisieren kann.
Da gibt es auch Erweiterungen, zum Beispiel wenn du Filmschnitt machst, wo du eigentlich keinen Bock auf musikalische Tempoangaben hast, sondern einfach nur die Uhrzeiten, die du freien Zahlen angeben kannst. Da gibt es dann auch so ein MIDI-Time.
Was ich jetzt sehr viel spannender finde, und für mich auch immer so ein Rätsel ist, sind diese ganzen Realtimesachen. Also gerade so, es gibt so eine Nachricht Clock, was tut das und welche Rolle spielt das?
Die Clock wird benutzt, um verschiedene Geräte untereinander zu synchronisieren. Das reicht ja nicht, Start und Stop zu sagen, sondern die müssen ja auch in derselben Geschwindigkeit laufen. Und zwar auch über eine längere Zeit hinaus. Da reicht es auch nicht, 120 BPM auf dem einen einzustellen und 120 auf dem anderen dann startzudrücken. Weil irgendwann laufen die halt auseinander. Und deswegen wird die Clock-Nachricht benutzt. Es wird auf jeder 96. Note geschickt. Also es gibt die Viertelnote, das ist halt ein Beat. Und dann gibt es 16. Noten, 4 Pro. Und dann 6 Pro, 16.
Das ist aber dann abhängig davon, was für ein Beat man hat.
Wenn man bei 120 BPM MIDI-Clocks rausschickt, dann brauchen die ein paar MIDI-Sekunden, um da durchzugehen. Und darauf kannst du dich dann synchronisieren, diese Zeitspanne zwischen den einzelnen Clock-Nachrichten messen. Oder vielleicht auf jeder Einkommende direkt einfach nur den Sequencer um 1 hoch zu zählen zum Beispiel. Da gibt es verschiedene Ansätze, wie man das macht. Und damit kannst du verschiedene Geräte untereinander synchronisieren. Und da hast du oft das Problem, wenn du einen Computer nimmst, und dann schickt er ja diese Clock-Nachrichten auch rüber, die ja wirklich zeitnah ankommen müssen. Auf der Serialen ist ja kein Problem, weil das bald geschickt ist und dann ist er auch angekommen. Beim Computer ist dann immer das Problem, dass es noch über USB und über 5000-Layer-AP-Layer im Betriebssystem durchgehen muss, bis es dann wirklich bei der Software ankommt. Und deswegen jittert es oft bei Computern.
Ja, also das ist... Timing ist ein echtes Problem.
Genau, das darf man sich gerne in Forums angucken.
MIDI ist ja auch nicht besonders schnell. Was war das? 38000?
31000 Bits pro Sekunde. Das heißt, so ein Byte braucht 3 Millisekunden, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Das ist ja eigentlich schon eine ganze Menge Holz, ne?
Das ist schon eine Menge Holz. Was aber gerne übersehen wird, ist, eigentlich reicht das total, um einen Teil des Glock zu haben, weil der maximale Jitter eigentlich diese 3 Millisekunden sind. Wenn halt gerade das Glock-Byte rausgeschickt...
Aber wenn ich jetzt so 10 Tasten drücke, dann müssen die ja auch nacheinander geschickt werden.
Die müssen nacheinander geschickt werden. Das ist dann die Frage, wenn du halt irgendwie 10 Noten-Akkorde spielst, dann könntest du dich vielleicht stören, aber beim Techno kommt das halt nicht vor.
Na gut, also wenn du ein richtiges Klavier spielst, wo ich dann wirklich so mit beiden Händen unterwegs bin, ist das ja eigentlich nicht genug. Ich meine, der kleine Finger links und der kleine Finger rechts liegen dann irgendwie 30 Millisekunden auseinander. Das kann man ja schon deutlich hören.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich deutlich hören. Aber ich, also es hängt auch, weiß nicht, die Pianisten, die ich kenne, die auf MIDI spielen, die stört das eigentlich nicht so wirklich. Also erstens haben die da nicht noch fünf andere Instrumente, die auf dem selben Kanal rumspielen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob so eine 20-Millisekunden-Spanne wirklich bemerkbar ist, wenn du so spielst. Also bestimmt für bestimmte Perfektionisten wirklich, wenn du eine MIDI-Gitarre hast, wo dann komplett andere Latenzen entstehen, weil du erstmal die MIDI-Note von der Gitarre erkennen kannst. Da merkst du es, das wird aber auch irgendwie ganz schön gut. Und das ist auch eine Sache der Umstellung, je nach Instrument und nach Klavier. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Rhodes spielst, oder ein normales Klavier, hast du auch wieder ein anderes Verhalten. Da kannst du dich auch dran gewöhnen, dass zum Beispiel so bestimmte Nebeneffekte entstehen. Das gehört dir auch zum Instrumentspielen dazu. Bei der elektronischen Musik, beim Techno, wo es wirklich von Anfang an Maschinenmusik ist, dann merkst du es auch deutlich schneller, ob du da Latenzen drin hast oder so. Und eigentlich ist es schön, dass ich dann Techno mache, weil ich dann total akribisch darauf achte, ob jetzt meine Basetrum 3 Millisekunden zu spät kommt oder nicht, weil du das sofort hörst. Und beim richtig gespielten Klavier merkst du es dann eher weniger, weil es dann eh dadurch, dass es durch einen Mensch gespielt ist, fällt, ist es eh alles ein bisschen schwammiger.
Jetzt gibt es, um vielleicht nochmal diese Nachrichtenwelt noch mal plätzumachen, also wir hatten halt so... Die ganze Notenwelt sozusagen, Tasten drücken, dann so dieses Sequencer-Auswahl, also mehr so ein Automatisierungs-Fernbedienungstoolset zum Auswählen.
Controllerwerte, sehr wichtig auch. Also es gibt Noten und dann gibt es Kontrollwerte, wo du alles mögliche mitsteuern kannst.
Genau, also diese unmittelbare Steuerung, das ist ja sehr populär und das ist ja eigentlich auch genau das, worüber wir im Wesentlichen hier reden. Dann gibt es eben diesen Realtime-Aspekt mit der Clock. Dann sagt es noch Start, Stop, Continue gibt es auch noch.
So die Sequencer-Nachrichten.
Das ist dann, ach so, um so etwas zu starten.
Genau, also zusätzlich zur Clock musst du auch noch sagen, jetzt geht es los.
Und dann gibt es noch so dieses System Exclusive. Ich kenne das eigentlich nur, dass die benutzt werden, um so Software-Updates und so weiter einzuspielen.
Das sind einfach binäre Strings in dem Sinne. Und dann bleibt eigentlich ziemlich jedem... Es gibt ein paar Standards, dass du zum Beispiel Samples über MIDI schicken kannst. Da gibt es ein paar Erweiterungen, wo vom CIS-X-Standard schon feststeht, was die Nachrichten jetzt zu bedeuten haben. Aber eigentlich kannst du als Hersteller da einfach alles Mögliche reintun. Besonders beliebt sind halt Dumps oder Firmware-Updates. Oder bei meinen Geräten tue ich die Firmware auch irgendwie über den Bootloader, über MIDI-CIS-X-Nachrichten rausschicken. Und das sind gerade die spannenden Nachrichten. Du nimmst halt so das Handbuch, guckst mal, was gibt es so an CIS-X-Nachrichten? Und dann fängst du so an, hackermäßig zu überlegen, na, jetzt kann ich darüber, aber hier so das hier irgendwie umdrehen oder so. Und da wird es dann interessanter, gerade weil die meisten Synthesizer so die Möglichkeit geben, Dumps erstens runterzuladen, um zu sehen, was sind jetzt die Einstellungen auf dem Synthesizer. Und die dann auch wieder hochzuladen, dass du dann irgendwie einfach nur noch zum Beispiel Einstellungen randomisen kannst und viele Sachen ermöglicht, dann auch die GUI zu steuern über SysX zum Beispiel. Also ich kann jetzt den aktiven Track auf meiner Dwarfmaschine auch über SysX einstellen oder sagen, lad mal die Einstellung neu.
Das heißt, alles, was sozusagen über Standard-MIDI-Messages sich nicht so ohne Weiteres abbilden lässt, aber trotzdem unter Umständen automatisierbar sein sollte, das fällt dann unter Umständen in diesen SysX-Bereich? Genau, hängt aber vom Gerät ab.
Hängt vom Gerät ab und dann musst du auch immer noch viel von Hand ausprobieren. Dann merkst du zum Beispiel, wenn ich die Nachricht schicke, dann stört es ab. Das sind Sachen, die dann ziemlich oft vorkommen. Oder du merkst irgendwie, ich kann zwar, wenn ich im Songmodus bin, einen neuen Song hochladen, aber wenn ich im Patternmodus bin, dann nimmt er die Nachricht nicht an. Das steht natürlich nicht im Handbuch. Also echt so ein bisschen so, wie wenn du halt vor einem TCP-Port stehst. Und dann so ein bisschen rumprobst.
Das Schöne an diesem MIDI-Standard ist, dass er einerseits wohl verbreitet ist. Es gibt alles Mögliche dafür, Geräte auch heute noch neu zu kaufen ohne Ende. Controller, solche Duplikatoren, Extender, System, die es über andere Schnittstellen übertragen, über USB, werden ja heute auch schon viele Geräte angeschlossen.
Also beim Apple kannst du auch gleich über Bonjour hier MIDI austauschen zum Beispiel. Dann musst du im Audio-MIDI-Setup musst du... Wie heißt es nochmal? Network. Da gibt es so ein Network-MIDI-Gerät, da kannst du einstellen und sagen, hallo, ich würde mich gerne verbinden und dann kannst du Sessions aufmachen.
Verstehe, das heißt, die Rechner können dann direkt über Ethernet untereinander...
Ja, über WLAN und dann einfach Posts aufmachen. Und das funktioniert auch ziemlich gut, das zeigt auch gleich die Latenz an und zeigt welche Participants da sind. Das ist ziemlich schön gemacht. Und soweit ich das beurteilen kann, kann man auch relativ sinnvoll Sync drüber schicken.
Das heißt, darauf wollte ich nämlich eigentlich hinaus. Viele haben natürlich auch über Musik eingestiegen, aber eigentlich ist ja MIDI ein ganz tolles Hacker-Objekt, weil es einfach eine wohlverstandene Technologie ist. Es gibt zahlreiche Geräte, die das irgendwie machen. Also wenn man in irgendeiner Form MIDI irgendwo ranbammeln wird, es gibt das einfach immer. Und selbst in einem extremen Fall, wo du halt deinen eigenen Computer haben willst, ist es ein technisch extrem überschaubarer Aufwand, MIDI zu realisieren.
Ja genau, weil du dann nicht... Du sparst dir dann auch, wenn du so deinen MIDI-Stack hast, oder irgendwelche Software, die sich über MIDI steuern lässt, dann sparst du dir auch irgendwie, dir dein eigenes Protokoll zu überlegen. Also du kannst da auch deine serielle Leitung legen und dann anfangen, irgendwie Bites auszutauschen und dir irgendwie dein Framing auszusuchen oder sowas. Aber da weißt du halt, das kann schon erstens die ganze kreative Software, also GIMP kann auch über MIDI gesteuert werden zum Beispiel. Und zweitens kannst du in den Laden gehen und für dir für 80 Euro irgendwie so einen Chinateil kaufen, was dann irgendwie 32 Enkode hat. Wenn du die einzeln kaufst, bist du deutlich drüber zum Beispiel. Das ist auch immer so ein schöner Nebeneffekt, dass es einfach auch einen Massenmarkt dafür gibt. Und wenn du anfängst, ein bisschen rumzuproben, findest du auch immer so coole Nebeneffekte. Gerade bei den Elektronen-Kisten, die kenn ich ganz schön innig, da geht einiges. Bei älteren Geräten aus den 80ern kann man meistens nicht viel anfangen, auch wenn es da viel zu 6 Nachrichten gibt. Aber alles, was modern ist, da kann man echt schöne Sachen mitmachen.
Bevor wir noch mal auf dein Gerät kommen, vielleicht noch mal kurz im Nachgang zum MIDI. Das ist ja auch einer dieser Standards, die sich einfach so hartnäckig halten.
Weil er gut funktioniert, so schlecht er auch ist.
Genau, er hat seine Nachteile, aber die Nachteile waren nie stark genug, um das Ding wirklich komplett aus dem Feld zu bringen. Trotzdem gibt es ja auch verschiedene Versuche, das neu zu erfinden. Ich weiß nicht, Yamaha hatte mal eine Weile lang dieses Firewire-basierte M-Lan im Gespräch. Es hat auch nie so richtig eingeschlagen. Es gibt allerdings dieses OSC-Open Sound-Control, das versucht ja schon, sich als Alternative zu positionieren.
Es kommt auch langsam, dass die Big-Player anfangen, OSC einzubauen.
Was ist denn das Versprechen von Open Sound-Control gegenüber MIDI?
Die großen Nachteile von MIDI sind die Einschränkungen auf 7-Bit. Werte von 0 bis 127 sind nicht so fein aufgelöst.
Das heißt also für Regler, Fader und so weiter. Da gibt es ja dann so allerlei Tricks, dass man irgendwie so den Pye und Load und so.
Es gibt NLP-Load und Pitch-Wheelers, auch 14-Bit. Da gibt es tausend Tricks, das irgendwie zu machen. Aber es ist schon ein der Grundprobleme, dass die Auflösung, auch wenn es 14-Bit ist, ist die halt fest. Und bei OSC kannst du sagen, ich schicke dir jetzt einen String, ich schicke dir jetzt einen Float, ich schicke dir jetzt irgendwie einen Integer. Das kannst du irgendwie alles festlegen. Und da hast du auch nicht dieses Problem vom Adressierungsraum, dass du nur von 0 bis 15 gehen kannst bei MIDI. Beziehungsweise bei 1 bis 16 für die Musiker. Sondern du kannst ja einfach irgendwie Präfixe definieren. So wie DNS einfach sagen Cork, Punkt, Note. OSC kenne ich jetzt nicht genau, aber dann brauchst du nicht zu sagen, mein Cork ist auf Kanal 0 bis 4 irgendwie eingestellt, der andere ist auf Kanal 5. Und dann drehst du am falschen Regler, dann ist bald auf Kanal 0 und dann rast du nichts mehr.
Aber es ist schon absehbar, dass dieses OSC in Bedeutung gewinnen wird. Auch wenn es jetzt erstmal nicht dazu führt, dass MIDI jetzt komplett aus dem Feld ist. Das wird es immer geben wahrscheinlich. Zumindest auf Absehbares immer.
Ja, weil es auch so einen Vintage-Fittishismus gibt. Deswegen verschwindet es auch. Aber jetzt gerade so mit den iPhones und iPad und so, die benutzen ja alle OSC, weil die ja nur über Ethernet rauskommen.
Ach du meinst, die Anwendung, die es dafür gibt, die Sound machen.
Deswegen ist jetzt OSC, glaube ich, kein Schwerpunkt gekommen.
Aber die können ja auch über dieses Bonjour-Protokoll, wenn das irgendwie problemlos geht, das auch über Ethernet zu werfen.
Bestimmt, aber wenn du eh schon Ethernet benutzt, dann kann man auch gleich OSC machen. Dann kann man auch gleich OSC machen, weil auf der anderen Seite ist dann eh ein Computer.
Na gut, aber du willst ja trotzdem unter Umständen in diese MIDI-Welt wieder eintauchen.
Ja, dann gibt es so OSC-Bridges.
Okay, aber OSC muss man dann auch erst mal installieren auf diesem Rechner?
Das macht natürlich deine Software, weil viel mehr als ein UDP-Port aufmachen, ist es glaube ich nicht so, damit zu interfacen. Aber ich beobachte das eigentlich ziemlich aus der Ferne, weil ich, wie gesagt, eigentlich Hardware baue und da hast du schon deutlich mehr Aufwand, wenn du OSC baust, weil du erst mal einen UDP-Stack brauchst, dann Ethernet-Transceiver und tata-tü-tata-tata und dann nicht so einfach deine Serielle vom Mikrocontroller einfach anschaltest und dann einen kleinen Interrupt kriegst, wenn ein Byte da ist.
Ja, dann vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zu deinem Gerät. Was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde ist, was war jetzt so dein Ansatz? Also welchen Weg hast du verfolgt von der ersten Idee hin zum konkreten Hardware-Design? Inwieweit hast du dich auf schon existierende Lösungen eingelassen? Inwieweit hast du das komplett neu erfunden?
Also es fing mit diesen vier Potty, es war damals noch keine Encode. Um diesen Delay zu steuern, habe ich mir erste Leute gefragt. Und so von meinem Konzept her war es dann, okay, ich baue mal ein paar, die halt nur den Delay steuern. Das sind 10 Zeilen Code. Und das ist ganz cool. Aber trotzdem gedacht, irgendwie kann ich da schon mehr Sachen machen. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was ich mir damals überlegt hatte, hatte ich so einen Makro-Knopf, der irgendwie vier andere Parameter steuern konnte. Und irgendwie so eine simple MIDI-Learn-Funktion. Also habe ich angefangen, so ein Display reinzubauen. Das war so ein bisschen das erste Konzept. Ich baue halt zwei, drei Firmen, die was Cooles können. Und vertreibe das Gerät so auch irgendwie Closed Source. Und dann fing es irgendwie, dann habe ich diese Massenproduktion angefangen. Es fing dann erst mal damit an, überhaupt ein sinnvolles Gehäuse zu finden, was dazu geführt hat, dass eine CNC-Fräse angeschafft wurde und alles Mögliche. Und die Software wurde dann auch größer. Was heißt, du baust deine eigenen Gehäuse? Genau, also ich baue alles alleine so. Aber das fing dann auch an. Am Anfang hatte ich so einen Atmega 8 drin, der so 1 KB RAM hat und 8 KB Flash. Weil ich dachte, mehr als vier Parametersteuern tue ich ja eh nicht. Dann habe ich den bis zum Anschlag gefüllt, alles in Assembler geschrieben und so was nicht mehr reingepasst hat und gesagt, okay, nimm mal doch mal den Nix Größeren. Da tust du dir was Gutes. Dann habe ich den Nix Größeren gebaut und dann wurde es immer größer und es kamen immer mehr Features dazu. Und dann habe ich vor letztes Jahr auf dem Kongress, also 2008, einen Vortrag halten wollen über diese ganze MIDI-Hacking und wie baue ich Geräte und so, weil ich da voll drin war und wollte auch noch einen Workshop halten. Bevor die Leute jetzt irgendwie GCC installieren müssen und einen Programmierer und auf der Kommandozahl irgendwie rumbasteln wollen, habe ich gedacht, ich benutze diesen Processing-Editor oder diesen Arduino-Editor.
Also Processing ist diese JavaScript-ähnliche Programmiersprache.
Das ist Java und Arduino ist C++.
Java-ähnliche Sprache, genau.
Und die haben so ein kleines Java-Programm, mit dem du halt drei, vier Tabs aufmachen kannst, dein Programm schreiben können. Der ruft dann den GCC auf und schickt das dann alles hinter einem Knopf versteckt. Und da dachte ich so, ja, als Editor ist das ganz cool, wenn du mal für einen Workshop was haben willst. Alles, was dahinter war, habe ich dann weggeworfen. Also die kompletten Arduino-Libraries und so, das war eh nicht wirklich anzuwenden, weil ich einen anderen Chip benutzt habe. Und hab die durch meine Libraries ersetzt und meinen Bootloader upload. Also im Endeffekt blieb dann nur noch dieser Java-Editor da vorne. Und das habe ich fürs Workshop dann fertig gemacht. Und ich überleg mir noch ein paar Tutorials, sodass die Leute halt eine Note schicken können, eine Note empfangen können. Und habe es mir so ein bisschen zurechtgelegt und dann angefangen, auch selber Programme zu schreiben. Bis dahin hatte ich so 3, 4 verschiedene Firmen für meine Controller geschrieben.
Das heißt also deine Hardware ist nicht Arduino-basiert?
Da ist so ein ähnlicher Chip von derselben Familie drin. Also ich benutze denselben Compiler. Aber alles außer diesem Editor, der eigentlich derselbe ist wie der Processing-Editor, alles andere dahinter, die ganzen Libraries und so, ist dann mein Code.
Das heißt, du hast eine eigene MIDI-Library gebaut, um dann eben, was du schon gesagt hast, einfach dieses Parsing der Nachrichten zu machen. Das heißt, man muss dann nicht jedes Bit auseinanderknibbeln, sondern da kommt halt was rein.
Auf das Framework kann ich dann nachher noch ein bisschen, weil es ist eigentlich auch so ein Riesenteil. Aber jedenfalls habe ich dann, bis dahin hatte ich so vier Firmen geschrieben, zum Teil auch ein Assembler und so ganz schön strikt, so wie ich das für meine Consulting-Aufträge damals gemacht habe. Und da habe ich dann am Nachmittag in der Küche gehockt und habe halt acht Firmen geschrieben, weil ich einfach immer nur Apfel N gedrückt habe, vier Zeilen getippt und so, je er geil. Und dann noch eine und dann auch je er geil. Es war einfach so ganz viele kleine Ideen umgesetzt. Was passiert, finde ich hier an dem Knopfdreh und damit irgendwie die Reverb-Steuer. Und das war dann so in drei Minuten halt zu schreiben, weil ich keinen Make-File schreiben musste, keinen Brösel auf der Kommando-Zeile machen musste, sondern immer nur getippt und dann auf dran gedrückt und dann geguckt, wie sich das anfühlt. Dann habe ich gedacht, okay, wieso machst du das nicht Open Source, das ist eigentlich eh so cool, da kann jeder was von haben. Und viele Sachen kann ich dann auch Leuten anmuten, die dann vielleicht nicht so tief in der Programmierung drinstecken, wenn ich das Framework so gestalte, dass es halt easy zu benutzen ist. Also brauchst du dann nicht mehr die Encoder-Ticks zu zählen oder das Display anzusteuern oder das MIDI zu parsen, sondern schreibst einfach nur noch hin, dass du einen Encoder hast, der heißt irgendwie Blah und der schickt Werte von 4 bis 18. Wenn das Framework das irgendwie unterstützt, dass ich das so hinschreiben kann, dann kann ich das auch irgendwie viel mehr Leuten anmuten. Und dann habe ich in 2009 mich dann ganz schön vertieft in dieses Framework schreiben, GUI-Programme dazu schreiben, weil im Endeffekt ist die GUI dreimal komplizierter auf dem Computer. Auf dem Computer hast du eine Tastatur und eine Maus. Und viel mehr gibt es nicht so zum Interagieren. Und da kann es eigentlich schon passieren, dass drei Knöpfe gleichzeitig gedrückt werden. Und wie erkennst du das überhaupt so? Da kannst du einfach nur Mausklick erkennen und Keyboard-Eingabe und mehr brauchst du nicht wirklich. Und eigentlich ist dann diese reduzierte Interface ganz schön schwer zu kontrollieren. Wie mache ich das überhaupt? Auch wenn ich dann nur 16 MHz habe. Und da habe ich mir ziemlich viele Gedanken gemacht. Das war dann so mein Ausleben vom Engineering.
Das heißt, mit Arduino hast du eigentlich gar nicht so richtig in der Produktion ein Buch gemacht?
Ja, da eigentlich so ein direkter Folgeeffekt war, dass ich dann mich ziemlich genau über Arduino Bescheid wusste, weil ich das dann einfach einmal auseinandergenommen habe und so von innen angeguckt. Also wie funktioniert jetzt wirklich der Kompil-Vorgang und so, weil ich das damals gebraucht habe. Und dann auch gemerkt irgendwie, bevor du jetzt, ich hab dann bis dahin bei meinem Mikro-Controller in den Experimenten halt immer eine Lochrasta-Plative genommen, halt einen Chip und einen Quarz und zwei Kondensatoren und irgendwie noch einen Pull-Up für die Reset-Leitung und dann angefangen damit zu programmieren, hab ich auch gemerkt, wieso nimmst du nicht einfach ein Arduino, steckst ihn an, schreibst drei Zeilen, drückst auf rein und sagst, ok, cool und dann auch, wenn ich immer jetzt so eine Spielerei ausprobiere, nehme ich auch das Arduino, auch wenn ich die Libraries nicht so unbedingt berauschend finde meistens.
Was stellt sich da dran?
Na, viele Sachen sind auch einfach von der Umgebung festgelegt, wie schnell irgendwie das PWM funktioniert oder wie die Pins konfiguriert sind. Dann benutzt du Digital Write, was eigentlich ein Zyklus nimmt. Wenn du das ein Arduino machst, dann kannst du gleich irgendwie 300 Zyklen verbraten und so. So viele Sachen, dadurch, dass ich die ganzen Geräte mal in Assembler programmiert habe, wo ich mir denke, naja, irgendwie nicht so der Burner, so wie es dann umgesetzt ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite habe ich dadurch auch C++-Lieben gelernt auf dem Mikrokontroller, wo das auch nicht unbedingt so der normale Choice ist.
Der übliche Weg. Aber welche Vorteile hat es?
Dass man schnell Sachen ausprobieren kann. Die Mikrokontroller sind jetzt auch nicht so, dass sie jetzt alle nur noch 512 bytes RAM haben, sondern wenn du ein bisschen mehr Platz hast und so, dann ist es auch ganz cool.
C++ hilft dir explizit, das schneller auszuprobieren?
Da kannst du halt einfach effektiver programmieren damit, als wenn du jetzt ein C oder halt ein Assembler schreibst.
Also du meinst, weil du eine Objektabtraktion hast im Vergleich zu C?
Auf der anderen Seite kannst du ein C++ immer noch so genau deinen Memory-Layout bestimmen wie ein C. Wenn der Compiler das gut kann, was er oft kann, manchmal auch nicht, dann kommt aber auch Code. Also wenn ich jetzt Templates zum Beispiel verwende für bestimmte Sachen, dann kommt oft auch Code raus, den ich als Assembler hätte nicht besser schreiben können zum Beispiel.
Jetzt hast du also für deine konkrete Plattform, hast du dich sozusagen für ein eigenes Design entschieden, was eben nicht diesem Arduino entspricht. Du hast auch, sagen wir mal, was die Software-Ausstattung betrifft, so deine...
Ja, ich habe das ganze Projekt auch geforkt.
Genau, aber ich will jetzt gar nicht so viel über dein Gerät reden. Das wendet sich ja im Prinzip auch nur an eine spezielle Klientel. Mir geht es ja mehr um diesen generellen Ansatz des Selbertuns und was man dann halt bewirken kann eben jetzt konkret mit dem Beispiel MIDI. Es ist jetzt aber schon so, dass man, bleiben wir einfach noch mal ein bisschen bei dem Arduino, wenn man sich dieses Development Board holt, dann gibt es dafür auch schon MIDI-Lösungen.
Ein paar, weil das teilt sich ja die Serielle, die auf dem Arduino fest mit USB verbunden ist. Das heißt, man muss ein bisschen rumtricksen, um sozusagen ein richtiges MIDI daran zu schaffen. Das geht auch, da ist auch auf meiner Website, da habe ich da so ein größeres PDF, weil mein Framework dann auch auf dem eigentlichen Arduino dann auch läuft. Das ist immer ein bisschen tricky, aber es geht eigentlich auch ganz gut so. Man muss halt immer nur eine Leitung trennen, wenn das Ding riefläscht. Aber das ist halt nicht so richtig angenehm. Wenn es dann schon Rapid Prototyping ist, dann ist eigentlich auch schon dieses eine Dazubauen ein bisschen nervig. Aber da überlege ich jetzt auch, ob ich mal vielleicht auch einfach ein Board mache, was halt MIDI hat und einfach ein Arduino ist, aber schon richtiges MIDI drauf hat.
Wenn man jetzt mal so ein bisschen weiterdenkt, was man jetzt außer deiner Drum-Maschine oder irgendeiner anderen Drum-Maschine so mit MIDI steuern kann. Du hast ja auch, glaube ich, selber auch einige Experimente gemacht, was auch visuelle Sachen betrifft, zusammen mit ein paar Kollegen.
Dieses GIMP zum Beispiel, dadurch, dass du in jedem Betriebssystem schon eine MIDI-ARP drin hast, die du aus jeder Software benutzen kannst, ist es ein easy way, einfach Controllerwerte auszutauschen. Im Endeffekt brauchst du nur einen MIDI-Port aufzumachen auf der Softwareseite und auf der Elektronikseite brauchst du dann nur eine Note zu schicken, zum Beispiel, um irgendwas zu bewirken.
Na gut, aber denk mal jetzt weiter auch bis zu der Anwendung. Was ist so bewirkt, was sind so Sachen, die du selber ausprobiert hast oder die du jetzt mit der Beschäftigung vor deinem geistigen Auge siehst, wo heutzutage einfach noch zu wenig gemacht wird? Also jetzt insbesondere mit diesem Hinblick kreative Dinge machen.
Also das eine ist eben, mein Nachbar macht Visuals. Wir treten als Duo auf, er spielt dann genauso live mit seinen Visuals, wie ich mit meinen Loops irgendwie rumspiele.
Der benutzt dann auch deinen Controller?
Nee, da überlegen wir noch, was ihm dann am besten liegen würde, weil er dann doch andere Anforderungen hat als ich. Der benutzt aber so einen Monomy-Controller. Das sind so acht mal acht Taster, also 64 Taster mit LEDs hinten dran. Und das Ding ist Open Source. Und das benutzt er so als Controller. Da haben wir auch viele Sachen ausprobiert. Ich habe dann mein Framework so ein bisschen umgeschrieben, dass es dann eben so ein Event-System hat fürs Monomy und so ein GUI-System angepasst auf das Gerät. Ich schicke ihm dann meinen MIDI-Clock, sodass seine Visuals halt synchronisiert zu meinen laufen.
Also Monomy, das ist ja... Ach so, das ist echt Open Source. Das ist so ein acht mal acht Matrix von so Radiogummi-Tasten mit Licht dahinter.
Genau, also eigentlich nichts Besonderes. Das Gerät ist ziemlich nice gemacht.
Da kommt auch MIDI raus oder USB oder was?
Da kommt USB-seriell raus. Und dann habe ich so eine Software auf dem Host geschrieben, also auf dem PC, der diese USB-Steuerung macht. Aber das ist eigentlich nur die GUI. Also ich kann halt sagen, mach halt Licht an oder aus. Und es kam halt ein Event für die Taster. Und dann hat am PC auch noch USB dranhängen, MIDI dranhängen, damit er meinen Sync kriegt. Und im Endeffekt schickt diese Software dann noch auf einem virtuellen MIDI-Bus MIDI-Commandos an die Visual Software. Und die meisten Visual Software, die können eh schon MIDI, weil es da naheliegend ist, irgendwelche Controller dran zu hängen. Nur, dass in dem Fall der Controller halt nicht nur bestimmte Tasten in der Software betätigt, sondern auf dem laufen dann Sequencer, die er dann ausschalten kann und dann so Funktionen, dass er auf dem Mono-MI malen kann. Also er benutzt immer so relativ einfache geometrische Muster, Vierecke oder Kreise oder Linien. Und die kann er dann auf diesem Raster einfach eingeben. Also drückt dann zwei Tasten dann doch eine Linie auf dem Bildschirm auf. Und diese Logik dahinter ist dann schon ein bisschen komplizierter, als jetzt nur zu sagen, ich schicke zwei Noten an die Software. Und da sind aber plötzlich dann komplett neue Möglichkeiten irgendwie da. Und da sind wir immer noch ein bisschen am Überlegen, welche Schnittstelle ist jetzt wirklich das einfachste? Wie schnell soll das Sequencer laufen? Soll er irgendwie sechs Trecks haben oder nicht? Brauchen wir überhaupt einen Sequencer? Willst du eher so die einkommenden Noten von meiner D-Wave-Maschine haben? Das haben wir sehr schnell beiseite gelegt, weil du nichts mehr verstehst, wenn alles blinkt.
Dieses Mono-MID, das macht auch OSC, ne?
Das macht eigentlich nur USB. Dann hast du natürlich eine Software, die dieses USB steuert und daraus dann OSC oder MIDI oder was auch immer macht. Da nehmen die meistens OSC, weil das eher so ein Max-MSP-Device ist. Aber im Endeffekt sind es nur Bites. Machst du dann auch raus, was du willst. Und so gerade bei Visual-Software, alles was so ein bisschen live, Theatersteuerung, Lichtersteuerung und so weiter, die haben DMX und MIDI, sind dann so eigentlich die zwei maßgebenden Protokolle. Und was habe ich sonst noch gebaut? Ich habe mal MIDI in Processing oft benutzt. Also ich habe irgendwie grafische Sketches ausprobiert, gerade für meine CNC-Fräse oder irgendwelche Bilder generieren. Und da bist du ja meistens auch wieder mit der Maus am Rumpfuhrwerken. Und wenn du schon rein die Möglichkeit hast, dir irgendwie acht Parameter von deiner algorithmischen Kunst, die du da irgendwie bastelst, auf den Controller zu legen, dann fängst du plötzlich an zu merken, ey, wenn ich zwei gleichzeitig drehe, dann kommst du in Bereiche, die du sonst nie erforscht mit der Maus. Und kannst auch deutlich schneller einfach drehen, was passiert, oder sehen, ob es dann vielleicht kinetisch eine bestimmte Bedeutung hat, weil du dann durch diesen zusätzlichen Controller einfach mehr Freiheiten hat. Aber das war im Endeffekt einfach nur Controllerwerte rüber schicken, im Processing dann interpretieren und dann irgendwie den Rotwert darauf steuern oder so. Aber es ist ja alles offen gelassen. Das Interessante ist ja eigentlich nur nicht das Protokoll.
Ich starr hier gerade noch vollkommen gebannt auf dieses Monomi-Gerät. Ist das auch Arduino-basiert?
Ich glaube, da ist auch so ein Archmeld drin.
Genau, es gibt ein Port der Firmware auf den Arduino.
Aber da ist auch nur ein Admin und ein FTDI drin und irgendwie eine LED-Matrix.
Dann kann man auch richtig Programme drauf fahren.
Genau, aber im Moment macht die Standard-Software nicht viel mehr, als die LEDs dann auszuschalten und die Knopfdrücke rüberzuschicken. Der Rest passiert dann auf dem Computer.
Man kann Programme dafür schreiben, die dann da laufen lassen, und dann hat man im Prinzip den gleichen Effekt, wie du bei deinem Gerät auch hast. Dass man sozusagen mit einem Tastendrucklokal nicht den Tastendruck als Seuchen überträgt, sondern tatsächlich erst mal Code ausführt, der dann was man mal tut.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das Leute machen, weil dadurch, dass es auch USB ist, das USB kannst du nicht an Synthesizer anschließen, sondern an Computer. Dass die Leute dann sagen, ja, dann programmiere ich mal gleich auf Computer, dass sie mir die embedded Entwicklungsergebung geben.
Verstehe, cooler wäre es eigentlich, wenn das Ding direkt MIDI-Schnittstellen hätte.
Ja, da habe ich auch was in der Schublade. Ah, da hast du auch was. Weil du bei diesen Monomi... Also ich habe mir das auch oft überlegt, weil die Schnittstelle echt ziemlich cool ist, gerade wenn du Loop-Musik machst oder sowas. Aber wenn du das im Moment mit einem Hardware-Synthesizer benutzen willst, muss er auch gleich dein Computer aufklappen. Das ist irgendwie nichts für mich.
Ja, was ist sonst noch Ideen, was man so ganz gut mit MIDI steuern kann?
Im Moment hatten wir eigentlich eher so diese ganze haptische Interfacesache, wie kann ich dann eben eine bessere Maus sozusagen mir zurechtlegen. Aber du kannst MIDI auch dazu benutzen, um gerade mit Cis-Extrins oder sowas Struktur, also symbolisch, Sachen zu untersuchen. Gerade weil Musik doch sehr auf Regeln basiert, so ein reiner Tonleiter ist eigentlich eine ziemlich strenge Regel, wie du Sound organisierst, dir dann deine eigenen Konzepte zurechtzulegen. Also eben Polirhythmen ausprobieren, Sachen ohne die dann spielen zu müssen. Oder auch Sachen einfach untersuchen und sagen, das klingt ganz cool, das würde ich jetzt genau untersuchen. Ich benutze das zum Beispiel, um Polirhythmen zu generieren. Da habe ich dann auch gleich einen kleinen Track. Polirhythmen sind jetzt Gegenüber-Einander-Stellungen von verschiedenen Rhythmen. Also zum Beispiel im Techno diesen 4-4er Grundrhythmus mit der Bassform, die halt auf jeden Beat knallt und dann die Snare knallt auf 2 und 4 und die Hi-Hatch immer dazwischen. Und Polirhythmus jetzt, wenn du zum Beispiel eine 3er Sequenz dagegen legst und 3 gegen 4, das fängt sich dann irgendwie nach 3 Takten wieder zusammen. Das sind so Sachen, erstens die von Hand einzuklicken ins Ableton, das geht dann relativ einfach. Aber es ist ziemlich spannend, das dann einfach mit ein paar Knopfbewegungen zu untersuchen. Da gibt es einen ziemlich coolen Algorithmus, so der Euclid-Algorithmus, eigentlich um den größten gemeinsamen Teiler von zwei Zahlen zu finden. Den kannst du auch anwenden. Also es ist eigentlich so ein Grundalgorithmus, der auch benutzt wird, um irgendwie Anti-Aliasing bei Linien zu zeichnen. Dann kannst du auch auf Musik anwenden. Ich denke, das ist irgendwie so was fundamental menschliches, so im Hirn, wie das funktioniert. Das ist halt irgendwie sowohl bei der Musik, als auch bei der Grafik, als auch bei alles Möglichen irgendwie ganz gut funktioniert. Und das ist jetzt hier zum Beispiel ein Stück, wo jede melodische Linie, also das Grundrhythmus ist halt da, es macht irgendwie so... Und alles, was melodisch ist, ist dann so aus diesem Algorithmus entstanden. Das sind so Sachen, die dann im Controller-Feel klingt halt irgendwie echt einfach grausam. Wenn du aber ja nur einen Knopf bewegst, und dann kommt was Neues raus, kannst du schnell so einen ganz großen Bereich untersuchen. Also zum Beispiel die Linie jetzt. Merkst du, den klingt irgendwie natürlich, aber schon ein bisschen schräg so.
Bisschen kaputt?
Bisschen kaputt und jetzt kommt die Bass drum rein, dann macht es wieder ein bisschen mehr Sinn. Und jetzt diese Gegenüberstellung, das ist halt ein Siebener gegen ein Vierer. Und hat halt, es ist eigentlich einfach zu verstehen, aber wenn du drauf zuhörst, dann rast du nicht so wirklich, was abgeht so. Wie hilft dir jetzt das Mini an der Stelle? Ich stelle auf meinem Controller immer so drei, sieben und randomize so ein bisschen und dann kommen halt neue Bass-Linien rein oder so.
Randomize, das heißt du hast auch einen Zufallsgenerator mit dem Schmier?
Ja, die Tonhöhen werden immer so ein bisschen zufällig ausgewählt so. Das kannst du einstellen, so Tonleiter, Peguio-mäßig und so weiter. Und dann drückst du halt fünf Mal drauf, bis was Cooles rauskommt. Und dann kannst du dir das immer verfeinern, und so ist es dann so ein bisschen...
Zufallsmusik.
Genau. Aber im Endeffekt wehst du es dann auch nachher aus. Also bei der Musik immer, dass wenn Fehler passieren und dann plötzlich was Cooles entstanden ist, dann nimmst du dir das als Grundlage für... Da hört man auch so das Aufdrehen vom Delay oder so. Und das sind zwei Takte, die jetzt gerade laufen. Das verstehst du nicht so unmittelbar. Und diese Möglichkeiten, also das ist jetzt nicht die Haptik. Ich tue da ja nichts verändern, sondern es ist einfach so ein exploratorisches Studiotool. Ich setze mich hin und überlege ein bisschen, so wie als hätte ich jetzt einen Tonleiter in einer Akkordfolge und überlege dann ein bisschen, welcher Akkord wird denn vielleicht besser reinpassen. Da ist dann auch nicht möglich, auf den Controller dann einfach, hast du alle möglichen Akkorde, die es gibt, bereit. Dann brauchst du nicht mehr irgendwie im Sequencer dann die einzelnen Noten zum Beispiel einzustellen. Oder als ich Bass geübt habe, hatte ich dann auch immer so ein paar generative Sequencer, weil du dann immer so Übungen hast, wie zum Beispiel spielst du eine Basslinie durch den Quintenzirkel durch oder spielst du Dick durch den Quintenzirkel durch oder legst dir die bestimmten Sachen zurecht. Und da sind die Musiker normalerweise ziemlich schmerzfrei, sich das dann auch im Sequencer alles so von Hand reinzuklicken. Und da dachte ich als Programmier, ich bin doch nicht doof irgendwie. Das kann der Komm-Shooter doch für mich irgendwie machen. Und diese Muster, also gerade beim Rhythmus oder bei Tonleitern, bei Harmonik und so, die hast du dann immer, zum Beispiel Bachfugen sind auch nach sehr spezifischen Regeln, die man folgen muss, halt eingegrenzt. Und durch diese Regeln hast du dann nachher die Möglichkeit, dann wirklich den Raum auch auszuprobieren, weil du dann wirklich systematisch die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten irgendwie auswählen kannst und dann ausprobieren. Das geht dann mit dem Controller fünfmal schneller, als wenn du jetzt irgendwie vier Tage lang irgendwie Noten im kleinen Fenster rechts unten im Ableton eingibst. Und das ist dann auch wieder, wo du das halt nicht nur unbedingt für Techno benutzen kannst, sondern eben auch für alle möglichen, für alle möglichen Musikrichtungen, weil jede Musikrichtung an sich so seine Regeln hat. Oder wenn du auch jetzt irgendwie experimentelle Musik hast, dann begrenzt du dir auch so einen bestimmten Parameterraum ein, in dem du dann nachher anfängst anzuforschen, wie klingt eine Sinuswelle oder zwei Sinuswellen zusammen. Und das kannst du auch anwenden für Videoschnitt, hatte ich dann auch so Ansätze, dass dann... Ich saß beim Freund, der so Videoschnitt gemacht hat, so ein bisschen rumgeglitcht, wo er immer drei Frames genommen hat, umsortiert, noch mal drei Frames genommen, ein bisschen umsortiert. Das hat er dann tagelang gemacht. Am Ende hat er dann 20 Sekunden Film, die so ein bisschen vor sich hin geflimmert haben. Und er hat auch gesagt, jetzt höre ich mal auf. Und dann saß ich daneben und dachte auch irgendwie, hast du schon einen Knall, dass du jetzt drei Tage lang für 20 Sekunden Film hinzusetzen. Dann schreibst du auch einfach eine Software, wo du auf jedem Knopfdruck ein 20 Sekunden neues Segment rauskommst. Dann hast du plötzlich die Möglichkeit, aus den 50, die dann in drei Sekunden generiert worden sind, den auch auszusuchen, der dir am besten gefällt. Und dann vielleicht von dort aus dann zu eruieren, irgendwie so gefällt mir der besonders besser als die anderen. Dann ist wieder die Rolle des Computers da, dass er dein Denken beschleunigt, dass es dann einfach eine Denkmaschine ist. Das ist dann die andere Sache von MIDI, die dann ziemlich interessant ist, uns zu suchen. Weil es sind ja schon alles musikalische Nachrichten. Ich brauch mir nicht mehr den Gedanken zu machen, wie bringe ich das jetzt an meine Ohren? Sondern ich kann dann einfach sagen, wie klingt das jetzt? Oder musikalische Werkzeuge, wie ein Appegiato. Du gibst einen Akkord ein und der spielt dann einzelne Noten, die von diesem Akkord irgendwie abhängen. Das kannst du dann auch plötzlich deutlich breiter untersuchen, als wenn du einen fertigen Appegiato hast, der nur fünf verschiedene Modis hat. Da kannst du dann auch vielleicht überlegen, ich hab eine zweite Spur, die läuft, wo die Akkorde gesetzt werden, jetzt passe ich immer den Appegiato und diese Akkorde an. Das machst du dann über MIDI, kriegst dann die Noten von den Akkorden, passt dann den Appegiato direkt an. Kannst aber auch gleich weiterdenken und sagen, ich nehme den Akkord, der gerade reinkam, bewege den einmal im Clinton Circle nach vorne und mach den auf Moll zum Beispiel. Was dann ein normaler Appegiato überhaupt nicht kann, da sind es zwei Zeilen mehr. Und dann hast du plötzlich so eine komplett neue Richtung, die dich dann als Künstler sozusagen interessiert, und kannst sie dann deutlich angenehmer und ergiebiger ausforschen.
In anderen Worten, man schafft es eigentlich durch die Unterstützung des Programms, schafft man sich eine Automatisierung, die einerseits live interessant ist, aber dann eben auch für dieses iterative Ausprobieren ist. Also das Ausprobieren selber wird einfach schmerzfreier, sodass man dann am Ende vielleicht mehr ausprobiert und einfach zu anderen Ergebnissen kommt, weil sonst der Weg einfach zu lang gewesen wäre.
Genau, also immer wenn du merkst, jetzt fange ich an, irgendwas zu machen, was der Computer halt selber machen könnte, was man eigentlich nur als Programmierer weiß, was kann jetzt der Computer, oder was denn genau diese Programmierschwierigkeit ist. Bestimmte Sachen scheinen relativ einfach zu sein, aber es kann der Computer echt schlecht machen, so Spracherkennung.
Aber geht der Trend nicht auch jetzt in den Erzeugerprogrammen, so, also MAX ist ja, MAX-MSP ist ja so eine Software, die ja auch so ein Skripting auf einem bestimmten Layer ermöglicht. Geht es nicht auch an der Seite so in diese Richtung, dass man auch nicht dann generiert?
Das ist ja genau ein Werkzeug, was dafür gebaut wurde, um solche Sachen zu untersuchen. Nur, dass du bei MAX, wie gesagt, nicht diese Einfachheit hast, dass so symbolische Sachen, also echt so Sachen einfach drei Noten zu kopieren in anderen Buffer oder in anderen Sequenzen. Das ist in MAX, das ist irre, nervig.
Verstehe.
Weil es dann schon irgendwie so gedacht ist, die ganzen Künstler, die verstehen das mit dem Programmieren nicht. Was auch nicht wirklich falsch ist, weil das Programmieren schon schwer ist. Aber dann eben diese Programme auch nicht unbedingt, die die Kraft des Computers ausnutzen. Im Endeffekt sind es wirklich nur Bits und Bytes. Und es gibt halt bestimmte Arten, damit umzugehen, die besonders praktisch sind, wenn du MAX hast. Also gerade so Klangverarbeitung zum Beispiel. Wenn du wirklich so ein Signalflow hast, dann ist es richtig cool, weil du dann code-mäßig deine DSB-Formel hinschreibst und nichts verstehst. Aber auf der anderen Seite, für viele Sachen, die dann mit der symbolischen, mit den ganzen Regeln orientiert zu tun haben, dann lohnt es sich, dann schon eher eine normale Programmiersprache zu nehmen. Und das kannst du echt auf tausend Sachen anwenden. Zum Beispiel, was oft gemacht wird bei elektronischer Musik, ist nur so kleine Sample-Stückchen zu benutzen und dann verschiedene einzusetzen. Und dann kannst du auch ein Programm schreiben, was dich nach Tonhöhe sortiert. Dann sagst du einfach, ich hätte gerne ein G. Und dann sucht du aus deinen 80 verschiedenen G-Samples, die auch irgendwie Sprachsample sein können, oder ein bellender Hund, bild dir dann gerade der aus. Und dann kannst du einfach die Samples auf dem Keyboard spielen. Das sind tausend verschiedene Möglichkeiten, die da sind.
Dein System mit der Spezial-Hardware, das lässt sich ja auch relativ leicht simulieren. Also wer ja sozusagen auf sowas steht, kann ja auch einen ganz normalen MIDI-Controller nehmen, der eben diese Intelligenz nicht hat. Und dann koppelt man das aber ganz eben mit einer Software auf dem Rechner. Das heißt, man nimmt quasi die Taste nicht auf dem Gerät selbst entgegen, sondern die Software läuft dann eben auf dem Rechner, wird eben auch durch MIDI getriggert, aber setzt dann wiederum dieses empfangene MIDI-Signal in irgendeine andere MIDI-Steuerung von irgendeiner anderen Entität in ein MIDI-Netzwerk um. Da hat man im Prinzip den selben Effekt.
Da gibt es auch verschiedene Software, die das Ganze auf dem Mac gibt.
Wäre das nicht für dich eigentlich auch ein Weg gewesen, deine ganze Software auf dem Rechner zu belassen und dann einfach nur das Gerät selber ein dumpfes MIDI-Terminal sein zu lassen?
Das macht es ja auch. Ich kann mein Framework auf dem Host kompilieren und dann genau damit so umgehen.
Aber du hast auch die Funktionalität im Gerät.
Genau. Oft prototype ich dann manchmal auf dem Computer, gerade wenn es ein bisschen kompliziertere Sachen sind, wo ich erstmal mir keine Gedanken um Grammgröße machen will oder so. Da kann ich einfach die ganzen Firmwares auf meinem Controller auch auf dem PC kompilieren. Da habe ich im Moment keine virtuelle GUI zum Beispiel, wenn ich das wirklich auf mein Gerät abstimmen will. Aber da kann ich genauso dieselbe Händerstruktur benutzen und dieselben Sys-Exparser und alles mögliche.
Aber letztendlich, du willst es halt auf dem Teil haben, damit du eben dann auf den Rechner auch komplett verzichten kannst. Weil du dann wieder den nächsten Stress hast mit irgendwie, die Software muss laufen und dann tut sie es nicht.
Mein Konzept ist halt irgendwie, ich komme im Club an, habe meine zwei Geräte, schließe die an, fertig. Und alles, was darüber geht, das ist echt irgendwie anstrengend. Also es passiert auch bei Hardware natürlich, dass du immer so Totalausfälle hast. Deswegen war auch mein Konzept irgendwie, auch wenn alles abstört, solange die Drum-Maschine noch einen Klang produziert, auch wenn mein Controller abstört, dann habe ich noch wenigstens diese Minimallösung, mit der ich dann auch noch die Party durchrocken kann. Das war dann auch so eins der großen Dinger. Solange die Drum-Maschine nicht explodiert, können alle anderen Synthesizer irgendwie ausfallen. Das passiert auch manchmal. Das ist echt irgendwie so die ganze Stromverkabelung. Ich hatte mal einen Gig in Marseille, da kam so eine Frau an, hat irgendwie prompt ihr Wodka in den Stromverteiler reingeschüttelt. Da war natürlich die Drum-Maschine auch weg. Das besonders Schöne ist, die hat ihr Telefon rausgeholt und ihre Freunde angerufen und hat gesagt, ihr braucht nicht mehr zu kommen, hier ist sie irgendwie tot. Dann kam der Bartyp, hat den Wodka aus dem Verteiler rausgefischt und dann ging es dann nachher, ist mehrmals der Strom wieder komplett ausgegangen. Um 7 Uhr morgens kam diese Frau wieder, ist aufs Klo gegangen, ist dann wieder weggegangen. Das ist eben, wieso ich den Computer nicht benutzen will. Weil es kann echt sein, dass es auf meinem Arbeitsgerät ist.
Mir geht das ja hier auch nicht anders. Ich setze ja hier auch bei meinem Audio-Setup mittlerweile voll auf ein dediziertes Gerät. In dem Fall das Mischpult. Und wenn mir der Rechner wegbricht, dann...
Das ist auch die, die viele Musiker, die ich kenne, die das auch brauchen, dass sie ein funktionierendes System haben, die haben halt ihren Musik-Laptop und da ist halt nichts drauf.
Ja, jetzt haben wir das ganz gut umgedreht. Haben wir noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen? So noch irgendwie eine Grußbotschaft an die Massen da draußen?
Ja, außer dass das Spaß macht irgendwie.
Eine Musikbotschaft noch.
Ich denke, was besonders wichtig ist, gerade wenn man als Programmierer da rangeht oder als Techniker, ist, dass es sich eigentlich immer lohnt, das Einfachste zu machen. Also das einfachste Konzept und auch nicht versuchen, so Fehlermöglichkeiten rauszumerzen. Also es kann dann, weißt du, nimmst du dir irgendwie ein herkömmliches Instrument auf eine Gitarre, kannst du ja richtig viel falsch machen. Erstmal fasst du die an und dann kommt ja echt kein sinnvoller Ton raus. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz praktisch, wenn du es so runterbrichst, dass halt viele Fehlermöglichkeiten noch da sind, dann musst du zwei üben, dass du die Fehler halt live nicht machst. Aber hast du die Möglichkeit, erstens Fehler zu machen, die cool klingen, dann plötzlich zu merken, ey, es klingt ja ganz schön, wenn irgendwie eine offene Seite noch mitschwingt zum Beispiel. Es sind immer so Sachen, die dann plötzlich in eine komplett neue Musikrichtung irgendwie, oder weißt du, so wie Jimi Hendrix und sein Feedback so, eigentlich wenn du es genau überlegst sagst, eigentlich will ich das ja nicht haben. Und dann plötzlich merkst du, dieses ganze Gitarrengejaule kommt eigentlich nur daher, dass irgendwie der Verstärker zu laut ist. Und es lohnt sich dann immer eigentlich so, das einfachste zu bauen, als jetzt irgendwie sich sieben Wochen einzusteßen und versuchen so das perfekte Techno-Generier-algorithmische Teil zu bauen. Und einfach zu sagen, wenn ich auf den Knopf drauf drücke, dann kommt eine Basestorm raus. Da musst du zwar üben, irgendwie regelmäßig eine Basestorm rauszukicken, aber hast dann die Möglichkeit...
Also auch falsch zu machen...
.haptisch auch, ja, oder Variationen einzugeben. Und dann dem Algorithmus zu sagen, jetzt mach mal eine Variation, die so klingt, das geht halt nicht so. Und beim anderen hast du die Möglichkeit dann mehr Spaß auf der Bühne zu haben, weil du dann auch bei diesen einfachen Sachen unmittelbar merkst, was du selber bewirkst. Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie Zahlen eindeilst, dann macht es irgendwie auch nicht wirklich so viel Spaß.
Das eratische Prinzip kann und sollte beim künstlerischen Prozess sozusagen eine Rolle spielen, wenn ich dich mal richtig interpretiere.
Ja, genau. Also es wird ja auch jeder Kreative sagen. Die coolsten Sachen sind eigentlich eh immer die Fehler.
Auch beim Programmieren eigentlich auch nicht anders.
Da ist es aber auch wieder ein bisschen eine andere Sache.
Das ist eine andere Sache, weil ich mich jetzt konkret an so ein paar Sachen erinnere, wo dann einfach so ein Programm einen Fehler hatte und dadurch ein Effekt erzeugt wurde, wo man sich sagte, ah, interessant irgendwie. Das war jetzt mal nachforschen, warum das jetzt eigentlich passiert.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man dann als Hacker auch mit den Fehlern ganz coole Sachen machen. Das wollen wir auch nicht verschweigen.
Nein, das wollen wir nicht verschweigen, denn dafür ist dieser Podcast ja auch da.
Oder gerade, dass du mit den Fehlern dann auch überhaupt die Möglichkeit hast, in Geräte reinzukommen oder in bestimmte Bereiche reinzukommen, was jetzt mit Jailbroken oder PS3-Hacks oder so weiter noch eine ganz andere Bedeutung bekommt. Aber im Endeffekt kommst du durch die Fehler auch an den Kern ran.
Über die Fehler zum Kern, ich denke, jetzt können wir es ja auch mal abschließen. Vielen Dank, Manuel. Für die Ausführungen, ich fand es jetzt alles so philosophisch, wie ich es mir ursprünglich hier erhofft hatte. Trotzdem auch ein bisschen Technik dabei. Das war's.
Wer sich die Technik drinnen geben will, können auf meiner Webseite ruidenwesen.com, das ist alles open source, man kann sich die Schallpläne und auch die ganze Software runterladen. Und da steckt schon ganz schön viel Engineering.
Also deine MIDI-Library und das MIDI-Framework.
Auch die CNC-Software, die ich geschrieben habe, die ganz coole Hacks hat.
Was ist deine Maschine?
Die Fräse, die ich habe. Von EHS ist das so eine Fräse. War leicht teuer, aber funktioniert echt super. Also ich bin ja total der Leie und hab's noch nicht geschafft, die kaputt zu kriegen.
Ja, wir hatten hier auch... Ich hatte hier vor ein paar Ausgaben basteln. Im 21. Jahrhundert hatte ich ja hier Frank und Frank Rieger und den Philipp Stefan da, wo es um die moderne Bastelgeschichte geht. Da waren auch CNC-Fresen ein Thema. Wer da Lust hat, noch mal reinzuschauen, das war Ausgabe 138. Da ging es dann um so eine Sache. Aber das ist jetzt hier nicht so sehr das Kernthema. Und jetzt sind wir eigentlich auch mit unseren Themen durch, oder? Dann nochmal vielen Dank. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hier auch bei der 145. Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express. Und es geht munter weiter, dieser Monat ist hochproduktiv.
Spielst du jetzt eigentlich einen Track von dir zum Abschluss? Oder kann ich da einen zwischenschieben?
Einen Track von mir?
Ja, so irgendwas, was du hast. Oder kann ich da noch einen von mir einschieben?
Du kannst jetzt auf jeden Fall gleich noch einen von dir einspielen. Dann endet diese Sendung mal ein bisschen anders. Trotzdem mache ich vorher noch den Abschluss-Dringel, wie sich es gehört, und dann setzen wir das Programm noch eine Weile fort mit etwas leiser Musik.